Here we are at Megan's wedding, it's 97 degrees I'm seeing faces I ain't seen in years, we're all praying for a breeze there are people I'm enjoying and others I'm flat out avoiding but we all agree this year's been pretty hard and we love Emily behind the open bar
我们现在在梅根的婚礼上，气温有97华氏度（约36摄氏度），我看到了多年未见的面孔，我们都在祈祷能有一阵微风，有些人我很喜欢，而另一些人我则避之不及，但我们都同意今年过得相当艰难，而且我们都很喜欢在露天酒吧后面忙碌的艾米丽。
wounded in similar ways wounded in similar ways it sounds in similar ways. It sounds like something that a hippie would say, but the truth is we're wounded in similar ways. But yeah, so I'm here with Jeffrey Seiler, who's got a new album out. I've been listening to that and then some of your other stuff. So I'm excited to get into it because I really enjoyed it. I, you know, how old are you?
以相似的方式受伤，以相似的方式受伤，听起来是以相似的方式。这听起来像是嬉皮士会说的话，但事实是我们确实以相似的方式受过伤。不过，是的，我和杰弗里·塞勒在一起，他刚出了一张新专辑。我一直在听那张专辑，还有你的一些其他作品。所以我很兴奋能深入探讨一下，因为我真的很喜欢。我，你知道，你多大了？
48. 48. Okay. So yeah, so I'm, I'm like about 10 years behind you. And the music scene, it was funny. You've seen this change over time. Like I've I've mentioned it as like a metaphor for some of my patients when they're talking about stuff at therapy and I'm talking about like individuation and now when you're a teenager, you relate to stuff or college and people around a certain age. You're like, yeah, the music scene, like if you weren't listening to Neutral Book Hotel, you couldn't date somebody.
48岁。48岁。好的。所以，是的，我比你小大约10岁。音乐圈的情况很有趣。你见证了这种变化。就像我有时会把它当作一个比喻，告诉我的病人，当他们在治疗中谈论某些事情时，我谈论的是“个体化”，当你十几岁或上大学时，你会和特定年龄段的人产生共鸣。你会说，是的，音乐圈，如果你不听“中性牛奶饭店”（Neutral Milk Hotel），你就没法和别人约会。
And that's so stupid now. But like that was where it was because you had to be understood you know or you know you had to know who the mountain goats were or something and then you start to get you know a couple years younger than me people start being like what what are you talking about you know um so it is wild uh you've seen that stuff kind of roll and change um but uh i when i i hadn't um you know really found a ton of new music that i was interested in so i get eight million requests from people and when your agent had sent me your stuff i'd clicked on it and just wasn't really expecting a ton um because i'm kind of hard to please music wise never really thought would sit down but i enjoyed like i enjoyed that album man i enjoyed i've been like listening to it you know beyond just what i would need to do an interview so and then getting into some of the older stuff where i
现在想来这太蠢了。但当时情况就是这样，因为你必须被理解，或者你必须知道“山羊乐队”（The Mountain Goats）是谁之类的。然后当你比我小几岁时，人们开始说，你在说什么啊？所以这很疯狂，你见证了那些东西的演变和改变。但我之前并没有真正找到太多我感兴趣的新音乐，所以我收到了八百万个请求，当你经纪人把你的作品发给我时，我点开了，并没有抱太大期望，因为我在音乐方面很难取悦，从没想过会坐下来听完，但我确实喜欢，我喜欢那张专辑，伙计，我喜欢，我一直在听它，不仅仅是为了做采访，而且还去听了一些你以前的作品，在我
could find it um so it's good stuff can you tell us a little bit about yourself and your history because it looks like you've been doing it longer than that one yeah uh i'm i'm originally from north carolina and um when i graduated in 94 i immediately moved to los angeles so i was a massive jane's addiction fan and so then um you know i was i didn't really understand how like in the 90s it was a maybe of a different scene because everyone it was like there was very strict lines drawn it felt like you know you were grunge you wanted to make sure you weren't a poser and uh those are the kind of things that can really impede your creative growth it's like really a fog when you're trying to find your voice and so i did my first album i moved to back from LA to Atlanta, and I started recording in earnest.
能找到的地方。所以这东西很棒，你能给我们讲讲你自己和你的经历吗？因为看起来你做这一行比那更久了。是的，我最初来自北卡罗来纳州，1994年毕业后我立刻搬到了洛杉矶，我曾是“简的瘾”（Jane's Addiction）的超级粉丝。当时我不太明白90年代的场景可能有所不同，因为每个人都划定了非常严格的界限，感觉就像你是垃圾摇滚（Grunge）乐迷，你得确保自己不是个装模作样的人，而这些事情真的会阻碍你的创造力成长。当你试图寻找自己的声音时，那真的像是一团迷雾。所以我做了第一张专辑，然后从洛杉矶搬回了亚特兰大，开始认真录音。
And then you just kind of found my voice along the way. I mean, when you read any of your early song lyrics, it's like reading your teenage poetry. It's bad. It's full of pretensions. You can see where you're hiding from what you're actually wanting to say. And does it help you find what you were trying to say, though, you know, when you jump back into that stuff? Big time. You know, it's I remember Mike Mills from REM. He said he always leaves like 10 instruments lying around and throughout his house. So he goes, I pick it up, you know, 10 times a week and I get the bad
然后你就在过程中找到了自己的声音。我的意思是，当你读你早期的歌词时，就像在读你十几岁时写的诗。很糟糕。充满了矫揉造作。你能看出你在逃避自己真正想表达的东西。但是，当你回过头去看那些东西时，这有助于你找到你当时想表达的内容吗？非常有帮助。我记得REM乐队的迈克·米尔斯说过，他总是会在房子里随手放10件乐器。所以他说，我每周会拿起它们10次，把那些糟糕的
stuff out of the way so that I can begin to write the good stuff so I can weed it out. And that's kind of how I've learned to have a much more forgiving filter where you kind of understand where who's in, I've, I've, I refer to it as who's invited to the writing process and when, and the editor is kind of like that uptight guy at the dinner party where you like him there. And, you know, three ones into the evening, he's good conversation,
东西清理掉，这样我才能开始写出好的东西，这样我才能把糟粕剔除。这就是我学会如何拥有一个更宽容的过滤器的方式，你开始理解谁被邀请参与写作过程，以及何时参与。编辑就像晚宴上那个拘谨的家伙，你喜欢他在场。而且，你知道，喝了三杯之后，他谈吐不凡，
but he only comes for dessert. And so when you're in that, when you're in that, uh, that open place where you're wanting to write and you're figuring out what you're trying to say, the editor's not invited. And so it's just kind of a more less judgmental,
但他只在吃甜点时才出现。所以当你处于那种开放的状态，你想写作，并且在弄清楚你想表达什么时，编辑是不被邀请的。所以这是一种更少评判的，
you know, vibe. And you, and you, uh, was there anything in particular when you're going through the younger stuff that you kind of saw? Oh,
你知道，氛围。那么，当你回顾那些年轻时的作品时，有没有什么特别的东西是你看到的？哦，
I was trying to say that in a messianic or an immature or a, a, a not quite, you know, full of the vocabulary of maturity way. But this is what that was. That actually is a cool idea. Do you find those in your younger stuff?
我当时试图用一种弥赛亚式的、不成熟的，或者说缺乏成熟词汇的方式来表达。但这就是当时的情况。这其实是个很酷的想法。你在年轻时的作品中能发现这些吗？
Yes. And there was this one song. And I actually musically like it. It was called Sharpened Your Essence. And I was just knee-deep, neck deep, probably in Echo and the Bunnyman fascination at the time. And, you know, with the English accent and that great hair and permanent sunglasses, you can pull that off.
是的。有一首歌，我从音乐上其实很喜欢它。它叫《磨砺你的本质》（Sharpened Your Essence）。当时我正深陷于对“回声与兔人”（Echo and the Bunnymen）的迷恋中。你知道，留着英式发型，戴着那副很棒的墨镜，你确实能驾驭那种风格。
But when you're a 17 year old with a thick, most Carolinian accent, and so you see that you were just trying to say something a lot more. I don't know. There's only so many subjects you can tap into. But I was trying. And I think that being obnoxious in those years helps because you're like, I've got to say something. But the floweriness of early writings gets diluted to actually what you can sit with and say yeah there was um there's an artist that i like that does um this comic called deadly class that image comics puts out that's kind of like andy
但当你是一个有着浓重卡罗来纳口音的17岁少年时，你就会发现你当时只是想表达更多。我不知道。你能触及的主题只有那么多。但我当时在尝试。而且我认为在那些年里表现得令人讨厌是有帮助的，因为你会觉得，我必须说点什么。但早期作品的华丽辞藻会被稀释，最终变成你真正能接受并表达出来的东西。是的，有一位我喜欢的艺术家，他创作了一部名为《致命班级》（Deadly Class）的漫画，由Image Comics出版，那有点像安迪
comic or whatever and the premise of it is kind of making the way high school feels like an actual worldview or actual like thing and so it's like the school for assassins where the kids have to learn how to be assassins when a lot of them die and it's super intense so if you pick the wrong click you know it could kill you and there's a lot of this kind of it's really good but there's this pseudo serious like ness that um you feel as a teenager um that is sort of made into a world and he said that if he didn't save his journals from being a teenager, he never could have written it because there was this just kind of like myopic,
漫画之类的，其前提是把高中生活的感觉变成一种实际的世界观或实际的东西。所以它就像一所刺客学校，孩子们必须学习如何成为刺客，其中很多人会死，这非常激烈。所以如果你选错了小团体，你知道，这可能会要了你的命。这其中有很多这种东西，它真的很棒，但有一种伪严肃感，你在十几岁时会感觉到，这被塑造成了一个世界。他说如果他不保存他十几岁时的日记，他永远也写不出这部作品，因为当时有一种近视的、
unquestioning intensity that you had to go back and find or else you could never remember, you know? Or, you know, and I think there is something to that. I've found some journals from college and like, woo, woo Lord. Yeah. I love,
不容置疑的强度，你必须回去寻找，否则你永远记不起来，你知道吗？或者，你知道，我认为这确实有道理。我找到了一些大学时的日记，天哪。是的，我喜欢，
I was listening to, like I've got a, we're renovating an old home from 1908, just north of Austin. And so I've just had this huge lawn. And so I have all the time in the world to just listen to podcasts. And I was listening to a Brene Brown interview where she calls it the, she calls her high school years, the cafeteria. It's like the cafeteria period where you don't
我当时在听，我有一个，我们正在翻修奥斯汀以北的一栋1908年的老房子。所以我有一大片草坪。所以我有很多时间可以听播客。我当时在听布琳·布朗（Brene Brown）的采访，她把她的高中岁月称为“自助餐厅”。就像自助餐厅时期，你不知道
know where you can sit in the cafeteria and there's tables that you want to sit at. And there's tables that you know that you're only going to be allowed to say that. And that's when I heard that, it just, I know exactly that feeling. I can picture the cafeteria and I can even remember specifically sitting at the table and this girl, Daniel Hong going, since when are you sitting at the popular table? And I just felt like a, like a, like a balloon turned into a raisin right there but that same precariousness you need in songwriting because you go can i pull this off yeah i think i survived just by kind of uh playing dumb you know people like this table what's it's so good about this table?
在自助餐厅里能坐在哪里，有些桌子你想坐。还有些桌子你知道你只会被允许坐在那里。当我听到那个时，我完全明白那种感觉。我可以想象出那个自助餐厅，甚至能具体记得坐在那张桌子旁，那个叫丹尼尔·洪的女孩说：“你从什么时候开始坐在受欢迎的桌子旁了？”我当时感觉就像一个气球当场变成了一颗葡萄干。但那种不安全感在歌曲创作中是需要的，因为你会问：我能做到吗？是的，我想我只是通过装傻活了下来，你知道，人们喜欢这张桌子，这张桌子有什么好的？
You can have it. I think people thought I was playing dumb and I was like, no, I'm playing trying to play as hard as I can. Well, so you had said that you're in LA to do music or in LA to do what when you head
你可以坐。我想人们以为我在装傻，而我当时想，不，我是在尽我所能地去演。好吧，所以你说你去洛杉矶是为了做音乐，或者当你去那里时是为了做什么？
down there you know like when i would watch videos yeah when when i was watching videos i didn't understand the difference between a different scene like i was seeing bands all the time when i would go down to atlanta and it was like punk and you know ska and stuff like that. And I kind of always thought that whatever my experience was, it was second tier to true artist statements. And so when I saw Los Angeles, I mean, I was into the Chili Peppers and Mother's Milk and Uplift Mofo. And I kind of, you know, naively snubbed my nose when Blood Sugar came out because it got so popular and I was just silly. But I always thought that Los Angeles was this elevated place where, man, it's so pure.
你知道，就像我看视频的时候，是的，当我看视频时，我不明白不同场景之间的区别。我去亚特兰大时总是看到各种乐队，有朋克，还有斯卡（Ska）之类的。我总是认为无论我的经历是什么，都比不上真正的艺术家宣言。所以当我看到洛杉矶时，我的意思是，我迷恋“红辣椒乐队”（Chili Peppers）的《Mother's Milk》和《Uplift Mofo》。当《Blood Sugar》出来时，我天真地嗤之以鼻，因为它太受欢迎了，我当时真是太傻了。但我一直认为洛杉矶是一个高尚的地方，天哪，它太纯粹了。
And of course, you have no idea how, you know, cheesy and like that all cities can be. But when I came to L.A., you I, I just wanted to experience what that was. And, uh, yeah, I mean, that's what that, do you know the song on the album,
当然，你根本不知道所有的城市都可以是多么俗气。但当我来到洛杉矶时，我只是想体验那是什么。而且，是的，我的意思是，这就是那个，你知道专辑里的那首歌吗，
uh, history lesson part two, part three. Yeah. That's, that's a, that second verse is about that. It's like,
《历史课第二部分，第三部分》。是的。那，那第二段歌词就是关于那个的。就像，
by the time I got to California, I had a self-help section on my bookshelf between the mirrors. Yeah. Some of it was pieces of autobiography I could kind of put together and others were parts of autobiography. I was like, you know, you could tell it was something personal, but wasn't quite sure what it was, you know? Yeah. Yeah. And that, and the take the, even the name of that song was named after a Minuteman song. Cause they've got a song called history lesson part two. So it was just, it was a node to that.
当我到达加利福尼亚时，我的书架上在镜子之间有一本自助书。是的。其中一些是我能拼凑起来的自传片段，另一些是自传的部分。我当时想，你知道，你能看出那是私人的东西，但不确定到底是什么，你知道吗？是的。是的。而且那首歌的名字甚至是以“民兵乐队”（Minutemen）的一首歌命名的。因为他们有一首歌叫《历史课第二部分》。所以这只是对它的一种致敬。
The California that I learned was, you know, beneath the surface and the sheen that I loved and still love. It seems like people who were, I mean, they're still popular cities. It just seems like the relationship has changed, but it was,
我所了解的加利福尼亚，你知道，是在我所热爱并至今仍热爱的光鲜表面之下。看起来那些人，我的意思是，它们仍然是受欢迎的城市。只是关系似乎发生了变化，但它，
seems like a lot of nineties kind of, uh, aspiring artists, filmmakers, whatever saw either new york or la as the place that was the source that if you weren't there you were getting a watered down version you know what what is it about people of your generation why la and not new york you know what what was that appealing to that la was yours and new york was one that you, I think a lot of times other people, other types of personalities or other kinds of art were called to that. Yeah, well, it's funny because my little brother went to New York. He's six years my junior, but when he graduated, he went to New York.
看起来很多90年代的、有抱负的艺术家、电影制作人，无论什么，都把纽约或洛杉矶视为源头，如果你不在那里，你得到的就是一个缩水版本。你知道，你们这一代人是怎么回事，为什么是洛杉矶而不是纽约？你知道，是什么吸引了你，让洛杉矶成为你的选择，而纽约是另一个？我想很多时候，其他类型的人格或艺术会被吸引到那里。是的，这很有趣，因为我弟弟去了纽约。他比我小六岁，但他毕业时去了纽约。
And when, but he went to high, he went to college. But I always thought that New York was just a steeper hill than Los Angeles. I thought Los Angeles was steep, but I just thought New York would eat me alive. And then when Matthew did it, I was like, I so wish I had had that chapter. But then my wife and I did that chapter for seven years and loved it. But there's a certain regret of not having experienced it at a certain time but i mean you're gonna have that with anything so you can only be at one place at one time but i think that la held out this you know i mean i was i had the
但他去读了大学。但我一直认为纽约比洛杉矶更难攀登。我认为洛杉矶很陡峭，但我只是觉得纽约会把我生吞活剥。然后当马修做到时，我心想，我真希望我也有过那个篇章。但后来我和我妻子在那里度过了七年，非常喜欢。但没能在某个特定时间体验它确实是一种遗憾，但我的意思是，任何事情都会有这种遗憾，所以你一次只能在一个地方，但我认为洛杉矶保持了这种，我的意思是，我有
raymond pettibone books of art you know i was into the lore of what Redondo beach was and those, uh, books of poetry and essays by Henry Rollins. And then all the tens, gentle, tens, gentle, 10 is that,
雷蒙德·佩蒂邦（Raymond Pettibone）的艺术书，你知道，我沉迷于雷东多海滩的传说，还有亨利·罗林斯（Henry Rollins）的那些诗集和散文。还有所有的“切线”（Tangential），
how is it? 10, anyway, yeah. Tangential. Yeah. Uh, all those scenes that were attached,
是这样吗？10，总之，是的。切线。是的。所有那些附属的场景，
you know, so, I mean, I, there's a band called Thelonious monster uh he had a therapy talk show about uh rehab and recovery with dr drew his name's bob forest and i mean he was flea's best friend and he john frusciante was in his band before and that's how the chili peppers stole him but i mean he was introducing you know the chili peppers to peter hook from new order so i was just i read everything i could being in north
你知道，所以，我的意思是，有一个叫“塞隆尼斯怪物”（Thelonious Monster）的乐队，他有一个关于康复和恢复的治疗脱口秀，和德鲁医生一起，他叫鲍勃·福雷斯特，我的意思是，他是弗利（Flea）最好的朋友，约翰·弗鲁西安特（John Frusciante）之前在他的乐队里，这就是红辣椒乐队如何挖走他的，但我的意思是，他把红辣椒乐队介绍给了“新秩序”（New Order）的彼得·胡克（Peter Hook），所以我读了我能读到的一切，身在北
carolina and just living through spin magazine and all the odds well and then you start making the music that uh or the the scene how do you break free of the scene? Is that just kind of when college rock falls apart, you know, or the segregation between grunge and punk and, you know, classic rock and everything in the 90s? Where do you start? How do you, you know, chart that progression of time. Well, it's funny because at my age, I'm starting to, I've gone back to, I've gone with Spotify to start making playlists of what I was listening to at that time, like age specific playlist. And it's funny, it came from an idea. There was an interview with Joy Williams and she mentioned in the Parisis review where she mentions uh james salt or the author used to teach a course in authors uh what they wrote at the age of the uh class and i thought i want to understand what what albums i was listening to and why and then it tapped into some of the otter stuff that i make that i thought oh that that doesn't
卡罗来纳州，通过《Spin》杂志生活。好吧，然后你开始创作音乐，或者那个场景，你如何从那个场景中解脱出来？那只是大学摇滚分崩离析的时候吗，或者90年代垃圾摇滚、朋克和经典摇滚之间的隔阂？你从哪里开始？你如何绘制那个时间进程？好吧，这很有趣，因为在我这个年纪，我开始，我用Spotify开始制作我当时听的音乐播放列表，比如特定年龄的播放列表。这很有趣，它源于一个想法。乔伊·威廉姆斯（Joy Williams）有一个采访，她在《巴黎评论》中提到，詹姆斯·索尔特（James Salter）这位作家过去常开设一门课程，讲授作家在那个班级年龄时写的东西，我想了解我当时在听什么专辑，为什么听，然后它触及了我制作的一些其他东西，我想，哦，那不
suit a record but it should because i'm just giving a i'm not that i have listeners but that i'm giving the potential listener only you know two-thirds of the photo of my face or my person and so i started to understand how much I mean when that album Ween the pod when it came out I remember buying it and I mean they only had that one in the first one and I ate that up I loved it I mean this
适合唱片，但它应该适合，因为我只是给出一个，并不是说我有听众，而是我只给潜在听众提供了我脸部或我个人照片的三分之二。所以我开始明白，我的意思是，当那张专辑《Ween The Pod》出来时，我记得我买了它，我的意思是他们只有那一张和第一张，我把它吃透了，我喜欢它，我的意思是这
was before Push the Little Daisies and all that and you know the early They Might Be Giants that like those first two albums that was but that was so left of center probably how ben folds oh when he came out because exactly and i i kind of think i do therapy i think that i kind of there's these stages for me where you you start to understand certain things like someone's shedding the light and then 10 years later you start to
是在《Push the Little Daisies》和所有那些东西之前，你知道早期的“他们可能是巨人”（They Might Be Giants），那前两张专辑，那真是太非主流了，本·福尔兹（Ben Folds）出来时可能也是这样，因为完全正确。我有点认为我做治疗，我认为我有点，对我来说有这些阶段，你开始理解某些事情，就像有人在照亮，然后10年后你开始
accept it so you felt like there the process of therapy was helpful to you realizing that you could just kind of blow everything up and if somebody judged that then that that was what's going to happen but that the people who you were being called to when you were younger that you were saw something and they were just kind of blowing something up it wasn't like they were iterating on something else that was already out there and correct yeah yeah no no no it's it's actually perfect uh there's a rawlins band song uh called i'm a liar and he goes i'll say things you already know so you'll say oh he so gets me and it's i think that that's the process when you're when you're when you're doing like the like object writing like journaling and stuff like that you're trying to get to the core of what your issue is because like my big issue was
接受它。所以你觉得治疗的过程对你意识到你可以把一切都炸掉是有帮助的，如果有人评判那也没关系，但你年轻时被吸引的人，他们看到了什么，他们只是在炸掉某些东西，而不是在迭代已经存在的东西，对吧？是的，是的，不，不，这实际上很完美。有一首罗林斯乐队（Rollins Band）的歌叫《我是个骗子》（I'm a Liar），他说我会说你已经知道的事情，这样你就会说，哦，他太懂我了。我认为当你做像对象写作、写日记之类的事情时，这就是那个过程，你试图触及你问题的核心，因为像我最大的问题是
belonging and not feeling like i belonged anywhere or half someplace and the other half someplace else. And I think that when you start to step out of a scene, I would imagine, you know, exactly. And so you're, you constantly are, you're reading the rules, you're understanding them so that you can try and fit in. And then when you start to get a modicum of acceptance, you start to be able to read the room objectively and you go, oh, I don't want to be in this room. And so it's so it's it's interesting. It's just I even feel like I'm still there now. Like it's like the concrete hasn't hasn't set yet. What was helpful?
归属感，感觉不到自己属于任何地方，或者一半在某个地方，另一半在另一个地方。我认为当你开始走出某个场景时，我想象，你知道，完全正确。所以你不断地在阅读规则，理解它们，以便你能尝试融入。然后当你开始获得一点点认可时，你开始能够客观地审视这个房间，你会说，哦，我不想在这个房间里。所以这很有趣。我甚至觉得我现在还在这里。就像混凝土还没有凝固一样。什么是有帮助的？
I think it keeps you young. Oh, yeah. Yeah, I think people that make a certain kind of art tend to age slower especially comedians you see that kind of you it's like you can't even predict their age their perspective has to be so relevant because and i think that is it's an active listening to yourself in the world to be like what am i saying how do i say it i have to say it different tomorrow they're kind of aware of that dialectic that even though I'm saying the same thing, I can't release the same album. So it's got to, you know, David Bowie's got to move on to the next thing, you know, in a way that does keep you relevant and young, you know, almost.
我认为这让你保持年轻。哦，是的。是的，我认为创作某种艺术的人往往衰老得更慢，尤其是喜剧演员，你看到了那种，你甚至无法预测他们的年龄，他们的视角必须如此相关，因为我认为这是一种对自我和世界的积极倾听，就像我在说什么，我该怎么说，我明天必须换种方式说。他们对那种辩证法有所察觉，即使我在说同样的事情，我也不能发行同一张专辑。所以它必须，你知道，大卫·鲍伊（David Bowie）必须转向下一件事，你知道，以一种确实让你保持相关和年轻的方式，你知道，几乎是这样。
Yeah, I'm working on a book about how songwriting works and just like activities. And so the first exercise that I do is I say, write down seven things that have happened to you in the last four weeks, because I think there's a separation between what songwriters, at least for me, think songs should be like what, what is worthy of a song and what subjects aren't. And then when you look at like the seven things that have happened to you in the last few weeks, then you can kind of get into the minutiae. And those are little windows into subjects that are rooted in deeper feelings,
是的，我正在写一本关于歌曲创作如何运作的书，就像活动一样。所以我做的第一个练习是，我说，写下过去四周发生在你身上的七件事，因为我认为歌曲作者认为歌曲应该是什么样子的，至少对我来说，什么是值得写成歌曲的，什么主题不是，这之间存在一种隔阂。然后当你看看过去几周发生在你身上的七件事时，你就可以进入细节。那些是通向植根于更深层感受的主题的小窗口，
like getting cut off in traffic twice, you know, might, you know, trickle down into feeling invisible and all those little things. But I'm kind of very open about where it can lead. I think Vic Chestnut, the songwriter Vic Chestnut, really opened that attic door to me because he would just write about any and everything. And I was like, and he's from Georgia. And so it's a strange way that someone from your locale doing it uh was it in a weird way it gives you permission
比如在交通中两次被切断，你知道，可能会涓滴成一种被忽视的感觉，所有那些小事。但我对它能引向哪里非常开放。我认为维克·切斯纳特（Vic Chestnut），歌曲作者维克·切斯纳特，真的为我打开了那个阁楼的门，因为他会写任何事情。我当时想，而且他是佐治亚州人。所以这是一种奇怪的方式，来自你当地的人这样做，这在某种奇怪的方式上给了你许可。
i don't think that artists should wait for permission but i think that a lot of people a lot of artists do and uh you know seeing vick and i got to sit with him on his porch for a couple of hours and you hear jeff mangum go i moved to uh i moved to athens to find god and instead i found vick chestnut yeah elephant six collective i mean that really was uh something that kind of passively changed music for about a decade and the way it was made and just even the even the network i mean everything was it was kind of a reference point uh when i was in school because you had i don't know i mean you see you're talking about grunge you're a little bit older than me it may be interesting before we get into like your style and your genre to just kind of hop through some of the kind of peaks and swells of the culture of music especially uh since some of the people are younger and they may not
我不认为艺术家应该等待许可，但我认为很多人，很多艺术家确实在等。而且，你知道，看到维克，我有幸在他的门廊上和他坐了几个小时，你听到杰夫·曼格姆（Jeff Mangum）说，我搬到雅典去寻找上帝，结果却找到了维克·切斯纳特。是的，“大象六号集体”（Elephant Six Collective），我的意思是那确实是某种被动地改变了音乐十年以及制作方式的东西，甚至连网络，我的意思是所有的一切，它在我在学校时是一个参考点，因为你有，我不知道，我的意思是你在谈论垃圾摇滚，你比我大一点，在我们进入你的风格和流派之前，简单地跳过一些音乐文化的巅峰和浪潮可能会很有趣，特别是考虑到有些人更年轻，他们可能甚至
even be aware of those movements but i mean i i remembered kind of gen xy people had to pick between um you know a couple scenes like there were less scenes for them than there were for me you know it was kind of like cobain was someone you couldn't ignore and Grunge was kind of going out. It was like what everybody's older brother listened to. I mean, what was your experience with that, the post-punk and all that stuff? I think the first or the second band I ever saw was Mudhoney on the Every Good Boy Deserves Fudge tour. And you're almost in disbelief because when you're in North Carolina, I finally was able to get cable when I was like 15. I can remember we would watch 120 Minutes and Smells Like Teen Spirit was debuted on
不知道那些运动，但我记得X世代的人必须在几个场景之间做出选择，比如他们比我少一些场景，你知道，这有点像科本（Cobain）是你无法忽视的人，而垃圾摇滚正在消退。这就像每个人哥哥听的东西。我的意思是，你对那个后朋克和所有那些东西的经历是什么？我想我看到的第一或第二个乐队是“泥泞蜂蜜”（Mudhoney），在《Every Good Boy Deserves Fudge》巡演上。你几乎不敢相信，因为当你在北卡罗来纳州时，我15岁时终于能装上有线电视了。我记得我们会在午夜观看《120分钟》（120 Minutes），《Smells Like Teen Spirit》就是在
that at midnight. And, you know, I didn't know Bleach. And I heard that song. And I always VHSed all of 120 Minutes. And I remember waking my little brother up the next day before school to play him that song. And we were both like, it was unheard of how monumental. I mean, you just felt like it ushered in a, I mean, that one riff. It's the power of just one idea. And it was, I think that when I'm hanging out, like a friend of mine, Honey, in Australia, she is 17, and her mom has been one of our best friends.
那个节目上首播的。而且，你知道，我不知道《Bleach》。我听到了那首歌。我总是把所有的《120分钟》录在VHS录像带上。我记得第二天上学前把我弟弟叫醒，放那首歌给他听。我们俩都觉得，那真是闻所未闻的纪念碑式作品。我的意思是，你只是觉得它开启了一个，我的意思是，那一个即兴重复段。这就是一个想法的力量。而且，我认为当我出去玩时，比如我在澳大利亚的一个朋友，Honey，她17岁，她妈妈是我们最好的朋友之一。
And the context of hearing this song by Stone Temple Pilots, it just disgusts me. It just makes my stomach turn. But when you were in that age, you saw the rollout of all these bands. Nirvana came out the pearl jam was right there but it seemed like stunt double pilots was one of those bands that the labels scurried to get their version of an allison chains meets nirvana and when they came out and scott and i was you know part of the problem where i just saw people as posers, but I still stand by like Scott Weiland, just unacceptable. And, uh, but you know, like I remember when Alice in Chains, I mean, you would watch Headbangers Ball on Saturday night and Sunday night, uh, 120 minutes.
听到这首“石庙向导”（Stone Temple Pilots）的歌，它只是让我感到恶心。它只是让我反胃。但当你处于那个年龄时，你看到了所有这些乐队的推出。涅槃乐队（Nirvana）出来了，珍珠果酱（Pearl Jam）就在那里，但看起来石庙向导是那些唱片公司急于寻找的爱丽丝囚徒（Alice in Chains）遇见涅槃的翻版乐队之一，当他们出来时，斯科特，我当时是问题的一部分，我只是把人们看作装模作样的人，但我仍然坚持认为斯科特·威兰（Scott Weiland）是不可接受的。而且，你知道，我记得当爱丽丝囚徒，我的意思是，你会在周六晚上和周日晚上看《Headbangers Ball》，还有《120分钟》。
And I remember when Wood, that very first Aliceison shane's uh song came out so that was that was a really really cool time because i mean i saw a radiohead play a tower records the night before the bins came out and uh you know there was like 60 people there so it's i i still think that this stuff like i i was talking to a a girl who was 18 i feel like i'm talking about teenage girls too much but her uh i was talking to she and her mom and she was she made i go i don't understand where to like what the k-pop stuff is and make me a playlist and And so I just dug into it because I don't, I don't feel that the night, I feel that the nineties tapped into something as unique as what K-pop is
我记得当Wood，那首非常早期的爱丽丝囚徒的歌出来时，那真是一个非常非常酷的时代，因为我的意思是，我在《The Bends》出来的前一天晚上看到电台司令（Radiohead）在Tower Records演出，你知道，那里只有60个人，所以我仍然认为这些东西，就像我正在和一个18岁的女孩交谈，我觉得我谈论十几岁女孩太多了，但她，我正在和她以及她妈妈交谈，她制作了，我说我不明白K-pop的东西在哪里，给我做一个播放列表。所以我只是深入研究了它，因为我不觉得90年代触及了像K-pop那样独特的东西，
tapping into is unique is, you know, aiming dunes, uh, you know, I'm, I'm really open to just accepting that time moves on and I'm, and I love that it has,
触及了独特的东西，你知道，Aiming Dunes，你知道，我真的愿意接受时间在流逝，而且我喜欢它已经流逝了。
I would hate that if grunge just stayed what it was you know and it just kept stayed at the as the king of the hill i'm very happy that things move on well what's interesting to me i mean we talk kind of about like social anthropology a lot on the podcast and is it art mirroring culture or whatever and one of the things that's like you know like had cobain lived he probably would have just continued to change i mean radiohead's still around it doesn't sound anything like the radiohead from the 90s you know um he probably would have gotten into other genres and you know he was a talented person but i think one of the reasons why that um suicide is held up as so relevant to like a generation too,
如果垃圾摇滚只是保持原样，我会很讨厌，你知道，它只是保持在山顶的位置，我很高兴事情在向前发展。好吧，对我来说有趣的是，我的意思是我们在播客上谈论了很多社会人类学，它是艺术反映文化还是什么，其中一件事是，你知道，如果科本活着，他可能只会继续改变，我的意思是电台司令仍然存在，它听起来一点也不像90年代的电台司令，你知道，他可能已经进入了其他流派，你知道，他是一个有才华的人，但我认为那个自杀被认为与一代人如此相关的原因之一，
is it's like, you know, boomers never really gave up any financial control still. I mean, they just, just, just statistically they've got 80% of the country's wealth, but usually youth culture takes over.
是，你知道，婴儿潮一代从未真正放弃任何财务控制权。我的意思是，他们只是，只是在统计学上他们拥有全国80%的财富，但通常青年文化会接管。
And with Gen X, it kind of skipped them, you know, because they had these weird anomalies where the internet, everything they thought was cool was like gone by the time they graduated. And way it was kind of sad it was like they were like yeah publishing magazines zines rock music new york um and you know all these not those kids are using iphones and they don't know how to open a pdf and so it was like no one you know we have this crazy nostalgia where the boomers or the boomers are still you know financially in charge millennials aren't doing
对于X世代，它有点跳过了他们，你知道，因为他们有这些奇怪的异常现象，互联网，他们认为酷的一切在他们毕业时就消失了。这有点悲伤，就像他们是，是的，出版杂志、小志、摇滚音乐、纽约，而且，你知道，所有这些，那些孩子正在使用iPhone，他们不知道如何打开PDF，所以就像没有人，你知道，我们有这种疯狂的怀旧，婴儿潮一代仍然在财务上负责，千禧一代在财务上表现不太好，但他们有带爱迪生经典灯泡串的啤酒厂，还有跺脚拍手、跺脚拍手的励志民谣音乐，无论他们得到了什么，你知道，他们可以怀旧他们成长过程中的所有东西，但没有人回去重启《达莉亚》（Daria），你知道，没有人回去做X世代的东西，所以它确实感觉，我想就像科本是他们的家伙，当他，感觉就像结束了他的时代，他就像肯尼迪，你知道，我不知道这是否有意义，但所以，你知道，你有了，所以那发生了，然后你接下来有什么？大学摇滚，莫德斯特鼠（Modest Mouse），吉他摇滚有点回来了，然后又消失了。我的意思是，你如何看待那些接下来的音乐时代？
too hot you know financially but they got the breweries with the edison classic light bulbs on strings and the stomp clap stomp clap you know inspirational ballad music and like whatever they got you know and they get to be nostalgic for all the stuff they grew up with but no one's going back and like rebooting daria you know no one's like going back to gen xe things and and and so it did kind of feel i think like cobain was like their guy that when he was it felt like it ended his era he was like the kennedy of you know i don't know if that makes sense but so you know you've got so that happens and then what do you have next college rock rock, Modest Mouse, guitar rock kind of comes back and kind of goes away. I mean, how do you see those next eras of music?
这很有趣。我看到，我想，莫德斯特鼠第一次来亚特兰大是在《Lonesome Crowded West》巡演时。我实际上和艾萨克（Isaac）吃了顿饭，只是因为我在做一个简短的采访，然后当莫德斯特鼠出来时，我们只是聊天和闲逛。是的，非常好。是的。我记得他说，我住在一个空办公室里。我不巡演时就睡在那里。我当时想，有趣，你知道，我当时在吸收它，但我试图看起来像一个非常友善
It's funny. I saw, I think, Modest Mouse on their first time they came to Atlanta on the Lonesome Crowded West. I actually got dinner with Isaac just because I was doing a brief interview, and then we just chatted and hung out when modest house came out. Yeah, very nice. Yeah. I remember he was like, I'm living in a like an empty office. I sleep there when I'm not on tour. And I was like, interesting, you know, I was like, I was soaking it up, but i was i was trying to seem like a very nice
和非常悲伤的人，真正有趣的人。是的，但我的意思是，只是，我的意思是，我记得他们出来时，他们真的被贴上了，你知道，真的在抄袭“小妖精”（Pixies）的标签，而且，我的意思是每个人都对每个人很苛刻，我不，我不认同这一点，但我只是，我记得文章里这么说，但他们现场很棒。讽刺的是，在我看过的所有乐队中，我看莫德斯特鼠的次数比任何乐队都多。而且我很喜欢莫德斯特鼠，但我只是被给了更多免费票去看我的，我不知道为什么，
and very sad person real interesting guy yeah but it i mean just to i mean i remember when they came out they were really branded as you know really ripping the pixies off and uh but i mean everyone's harsh on harsh on everyone i don't i'm not subscribing to that, but I'm just, I remember articles saying that, but they were, they were great live. And ironically of all the bands I've ever seen, I have seen modest mouse more than any band. And I like modest mouse a lot, but I've just been given more free tickets to see my, I don't know why,
但是的，那，那很好。我的意思是，我在，嗯，杰夫·曼格姆和中性牛奶饭店住在雅典，有，
but yeah, that, that, that was good. I mean, I was at the, um, Jeff Mangum and neutral milk lived in Athens and there was,
嗯，所以我去了他们在故乡40瓦俱乐部举办的《In the Aeroplane Over the Sea》的唱片发布会。而且，嗯，因为旁边有一家唱片店，我不知道它现在还在不在，但它叫Low Yo-Yo，但我认为，我认为不同的，嗯，不同的声音色彩正在显现，就像当《In the Aeroplane Over the Sea》出来时，我说过我是怎么去他们的唱片发布会的。你不知道那来自哪个星系。
uh, and so I went to the record release show in, uh, at the 40 watt in their hometown for in the airplane. And, uh, because there was a record store next to it i don't know if it still is there but it's called the low yo-yo but i i think that i think that different uh different like sonic colors were coming to the light like with uh when neutral milk hotel came out within the airplane over the sea, I was saying how I got to go to their record release show. And you didn't know kind of where, what galaxy that was coming from.
实际上，它可能是“烈焰红唇”（Flaming Lips）和维克·切斯纳特以及所有那些不同事物的十字路口。所以那很有趣，我认为维克·切斯纳特为我解锁了很多东西，因为他只是深入细节，你可以模糊地缝合所有的小事，他会用像“平息”（assuage）这样的词，而且我，你知道，读了每一次采访，有一天在他的门廊上和他聊了几个小时的歌曲创作，这是我最珍贵的记忆之一，但后来那，你知道，你只是在拼凑你如何，你如何开始看待歌曲，所以那是，你知道，我能看到所有那些歌曲谱系，那些与我产生共鸣的特定时代歌曲。
And in reality, it was maybe a crossroads of Flaming Lips and Vic Chestnut and all those different things. And so that was that was interesting i think that vick chestnut unlocked a lot for me because he he just got into the minutiae you could kind of vaguely sew together all the little things and he would use words like a swage and he would and i you know read every interview and talked to him on his porch for a couple hours about songwriting one day which is one of my most treasured memories but then that you know all you're just piecing together how you how you're starting to view songs and so that was you know i i can see all that that lineage of the song era, the era specific songs that were clicking with me.
所以我当时想，哦。所以当你听到像Spoon乐队录音的细致入微，然后你听到像我们谈论的“大盗”（Big Thief），他们的，嗯，他们的松散，但仍然像，她是一个，她是一个曲线。好吧，你知道，
So then I was like, oh. And so then when you hear things like Spoon's meticulousness in their recording, and then you hear like what we were talking about with big thief, their, uh, their looseness, but there's still like, she's a, she's a curve. Well, you know,
长期参加者。就像，我不认识阿德里安（Adrian），但她是那些不熟悉，不在行业内的人的朋友。是的。所以这就像德克萨斯州的一个歌曲创作静修会，科罗拉多州也有，你只是和其他歌曲作者一起工作，不一定只是共同创作，而是演奏处于不同完成阶段的歌曲，你处于一个社区中，那里的人大多只是在
long time attendee. Like, I don't, I don't know Adrian, but she's friends of people not familiar, not in the industry. Yeah. So it's like a songwriting retreat in Texas and there's ones in Colorado and you're just working with other songwriters, not necessarily just co-writing, but playing songs in different stages of completion and you're there in a community of people who largely are performing
木吉他的伴奏下表演，所以没有太多地方可以隐藏，所以我喜欢那样，因为我会写下歌曲的版本，然后说，我不确定这句歌词。我以后可能会改。他们会说，为什么？就像，现在改。就像，决定你要说什么。我想，哦，那可以做到。而且那真的，那种纪律我回应了。民谣世界，但我同样与像“鹿蹄”（Deerhoof）这样的艺术摇滚世界紧密相连，我最喜欢的乐队之一是“火箭队”（The Rocketeens），所以所有那些东西，嗯，所有那些东西都是我成长的土壤，我想这就是为什么我那么喜欢那张专辑，而且我没有抱太大期望，就是那种民谣东西的融合，民谣的影响，但艺术摇滚是我作为一个独立摇滚孩子一直所在的地方，在大学里，当它开始走向不同的方向，一切都只是跺脚拍手铃鼓赞歌时，我有点退出了，而且，嗯，当我
just with the accompaniment of a of an acoustic guitar and so there's not a lot of not a lot of places to hide and so i i like that because i would have like say written down versions of a of a song and i go i'm not sure about this lyric. I might change it later. And they would go, why? Like, change it now. Like, decide on what you're going to say. And I thought, oh, that can be done. And that really, that kind of discipline I responded to. of the folk world but i'm i'm just as tied to the the art rock world of like deer hoof and one of my favorite bands is the rocketeens and so all those things uh all those things were the soil that i came from i think that's why i loved that album so much was and i wasn't expecting a ton was that that fusion of kind of the folk stuff the folk influence but art rock is kind of where i always was as like an indie rock kid and and in college and when it when that started to go a different direction and everything was just kind of stomp clap tambourine anthem i kind of checked out um and uh yeah and uh when i was
听你的时候，就像这是迪伦《Planet Waves》的松散感，他们在录音室里玩得很开心，没有太多的计划，你知道，就像我不是在听Cake乐队，那里的一切都那么干净，你知道，那么平滑，但同时还有这种质感，你知道，我最后一次在最后那张大盗专辑上听到它时，我当时想，伙计，你真的让我听特定的声音。这就像Wilco的《A Ghost is Born》，你不仅仅是在摇滚歌曲上狂弹。你真的在玩弄东西的质感。你们都做得很好。
listening to you it's like this is the looseness of dylan planet waves their people in the studio are having fun there's not too much of a plan you know like i'm not listening to cake where everything is just so clean you know like so so smooth off but then also there's this texture like you know the last i heard it on that last big thief album where i was just like man you're really making me listen to specific sounds. This is like Wilco, A Ghost is Born, where you're not just shredding on a rock song. You're really playing with the texture of stuff. And you all do that really well.
你喜欢那张专辑。你的专辑很棒。你和一起录音的人一起写了多少，或者他们进来多少，你知道，从歌曲创作营和Curve L到以那种形式发行专辑的过程是什么？我做这张专辑的方式是，我几乎把所有的结构都准备好了，然后我们去了鼓手肖恩在布鲁克林的公寓，他有一套完整的鼓组，布莱恩和布莱恩·贝坦库特（Brian Betancourt）和亚当·布里斯班（Adam Brisbane），我们只是坐在那个房间里，我们把它过了一遍，把歌做了两次，我为他们准备了松散的和弦图，我录了下来，然后我们等了两周，我所做的
You like that out. Your album is great. Are you how much are you writing with the people that you're recording with or how much are they coming in and you know what's the process of making Getting from the songwriting camp and curve L to getting that album out in the form that it's out in the way that I did this one is I pretty much had all the structure in place and then we went to Shawn the drummers apartment in Brooklyn and he had a full drum kit up and Brian and Brian Betancourt and Adam Brisbane and we were just sitting in that room and we went through it did the songs like twice I kind of had loose chord charts for them to follow I recorded it and then then we waited like two weeks and all I
就是仔细研究那些录音。然后我们去了布鲁克林的一间公寓，录下了所有那些版本。我想我们在第一次会议中做了七首歌，就像三个小时的练习，然后又做了六首。然后我们为这张专辑录了13首。我们没用三首。是的，所以我感觉当我有结构和歌词时，我的部分就完成了。然后就像，我不想保持严格的控制。我的意思是，当你演奏时，我想要制作这张唱片的方式是我只是尽可能多地去布鲁克林和纽约的演出，我想看当地人演奏，你知道，我看到，你知道，大盗乐队的巴克（Buck）他在一场家庭演出中演奏，我只是看着乐手，吸收它，而且，嗯，然后你说，好的，酷，我只想在一个房间里，我完成了我的部分。
did was just pour over those recordings. And then we went in an apartment in Brooklyn and just recorded all those versions. I think we did seven songs in the first session, like a three-hour practice, and then six more. And then we recorded 13 for this album. And we didn't use three. And yeah, so I kind of feel like my part's done when I have the structure and the words done. And then it's like, I don't want to keep a tight rein. I mean, when you're playing, the way that I wanted to make this record is I just went to as many shows in Brooklynoklyn and new york as i could and i wanted to watch the locals play you know i saw you know buck from big thief he play a house show and i'm just watching the players and just soaking it in and uh and then you go okay cool i just want to be in a room and just i've done my part and And then you like, I mean, Brian plays with DaVinger now, uh, you know, all these, you know, Sean, I think he's played with, uh, Kevin Morby and so forth. So then,
然后你喜欢，我的意思是，布莱恩现在和DaVinger一起演奏，你知道，所有这些，你知道，肖恩，我想他和凯文·莫比（Kevin Morby）一起演奏过，等等。所以然后，
then you just let them do their colors and then you're just kind of, you just kind of move in the canvas so that they can paint on it here. They're, like that and so then then when you come away with it you go okay cool and then i mean the uh linea from habibi she's a good friend and i mean man it was that was probably some of the most fun is like after we had done a lot of the backing tracks just linea coming over to my wife and us house and us just having fun with the background vocals. Cause we're all Shangri-La fans and Francois Harding. So just having that,
然后你只需要让他们发挥色彩，然后你就像是，你只需要在画布上移动，这样他们就能在上面画画。他们，就像那样，然后当你离开的时候，你会觉得，哦，酷，我的意思是，来自Habibi的Linea，她是一位好朋友，我的天，那可能是我最开心的时光之一，就像我们在完成了很多伴奏之后，Linea来到我和我妻子的家，我们一起享受背景人声的乐趣。因为我们都是Shangri-La和Francois Harding的粉丝。所以拥有那种，
you know, French girl background feel. And, uh, you know, my wife was like, listen to beauty school dropout, you know,
你知道，那种法国女孩的背景感。而且，你知道，我妻子当时说，听听《Beauty School Dropout》，你知道，
for a song like Jean Francois so that it's, it's not just one dimensional. It's, uh, got sonic depth of field and emotional depth of field. Cause you can't just be all the only, the impediment for me with goth was that it just seemed all dark. And for me to believe the dark, I need to see some of the light, you know,
对于像《Jean Francois》这样的歌，它不仅仅是单维度的。它有声音的景深和情感的景深。因为你不能只是，对我来说，哥特音乐的障碍在于它似乎总是很黑暗。为了让我相信这种黑暗，我需要看到一些光亮，你知道，
so that you see how dark is dark. Yeah, it's the contrast. Not that I hold out that way. I mean, yeah. Yeah, well, I mean, I think that's like the novice, like early novice songwriter, like when you're like 14 and you write your first song, it's always going to be like, there's no contrast. There's no story. There's no loss. It's just you're like, oh, I better get some serious images.
这样你才能看出黑暗到底有多深。是的，这就是对比。并不是说我非要那样坚持。我是说，是的。好吧，我的意思是，我认为这就像新手，像早期的业余词曲作者，当你14岁写第一首歌时，它总是会这样，没有对比。没有故事。没有失落。你只是觉得，哦，我最好找些严肃的意象。
And it's all like, I smoked cigarettes at the graveyard in the rain. Dad. And you got to start off, you know, like looking at the beauty of the oleander and then meditating on its poison before you smoke the cigarette in the graveyard in the rain. I love that you know i was thinking uh when we had been emailing back and forth to schedule uh you know you just think about therapy and uh when i was in brooklyn before we moved down to
就像我在雨中的墓地里抽烟。天哪。你得从观察夹竹桃的美开始，然后在抽那支雨中墓地的烟之前，先沉思它的毒性。我喜欢这一点，你知道，我在想，当我们来回发邮件安排时间时，你知道，你只会想到治疗，当我搬到奥斯汀之前住在布鲁克林时，
austin uh we were at this thai place called ugly ugly baby in Brooklyn. And so we were there with some friends and we were waiting on our table and then we sit down and literally, uh, so they get up to leave and I didn't want to bother them, but I just, I walked out as they were waiting for their Uber. And I said, Hey Lee, uh, my name's Jeffrey. And he goes, Oh, Hey Jeff. And nicest guy, just best, just the best experience. And I said, Hey, uh, I just wanted to tell you when I was like 16, I was like chronically depressed. And my parents made me go to see a therapist. And so the therapist was going, oh, you're really into music? And I go, yeah, I'm trying to get into this show, but it's sold out. It's this band Sonic Youth.
我们在布鲁克林一家叫Ugly Baby的泰国餐馆。我们和一些朋友在那里等位，然后我们坐下，真的，他们起身离开，我不想打扰他们，但我还是在他们等优步的时候走了出去。我说，嘿Lee，我叫Jeffrey。他说，哦，嘿Jeff。人最好，真的是最好的体验。我说，嘿，我只是想告诉你，我16岁时患有慢性抑郁症。我父母让我去看心理医生。医生问，哦，你真的很喜欢音乐吗？我说，是的，我想去看这场演出，但票卖光了。是Sonic Youth乐队的。
And he goes, oh, do you know who Lee Ronaldo is? And I go, yeah, of course. And he goes, he's my best friend. So I couldn't get it. I couldn't get into the show anyway, because I think it was a like 21 and older. But, uh, the next week he came back with a, with a note that said, hang in there, Jeff, Sonic life, Lee. And I said that, that gave me, it gave me chills just now because it was just like you saw these people as like everything outside of North Carolina just seemed like so far away and to see something and I was not like the person to have idol worship of these guys but it was they were unlocking and meant so much they were building
他说，哦，你认识Lee Ronaldo吗？我说，当然认识。他说，他是我最好的朋友。所以我还是没能进去，因为我想那是21岁以上才能进的。但是，下周他带回了一张纸条，上面写着：坚持住，Jeff，Sonic life，Lee。我说，那让我现在都起鸡皮疙瘩，因为就像你把这些人看作是北卡罗来纳州以外的一切，似乎都那么遥远，能看到一些东西，我并不是那种崇拜他们的人，但他们正在解锁，意义重大，他们正在为我搭建
a bridge to sanity for me and i was like that lee ronaldo would take that time so he was like i am i go i didn't want to bother you during dinner but i just want to and he's like i am so glad you came up he gave me a hug and his wife gave me a hug it was just really uh touching yeah that's really cool it's neat the connections that you're able to, you know, that you have through the music that you do. Would you say, you know big point that the singer songwriter is trying to meditate on you know incredibly poetically there's just kind of a subtle conversation and reflection about like isn't it kind of wild that that works this way and then the moment goes on like you're talking to the audience at a bar you know and then there's
一座通往理智的桥梁，我当时想，Lee Ronaldo竟然会花时间做这件事，所以我说，我不想在晚餐时打扰你，但我只是想……他说，我很高兴你过来，他给了我一个拥抱，他妻子也给了我一个拥抱，这真的很感人。是的，那真的很酷。你通过你所做的音乐建立的联系真是太棒了。你会说，你知道，创作歌手试图在歌词中极其诗意地沉思，这只是一种关于“这难道不疯狂吗，它竟然以这种方式运作”的微妙对话和反思，然后那一刻继续，就像你在酒吧里和观众交谈，你知道，然后还有
also um a con like a fixation on things that wouldn't normally be in a song you know waiting in a line at a wedding and counting your drink tickets you know i think the last time i heard drink tickets in a song it was uh like on the alopecia album by like why you know uh and which is you know he kind of does the same thing you know is is that something that you're aware of or is that wrong i don't know no no no it's it's definitely i mean it's like therapy you know like like when you when you watch therapists on tv they're they're explaining what your problem is but with all the therapists that i've had and i think it's like three or four they've I've always been underwhelmed by how much they make me reach the conclusion. And it's my understanding that that's the healthy way because they're not always
一种对通常不会出现在歌词里的事物的执着，你知道，在婚礼上排队，数你的酒水券，你知道，我想我最后一次在歌词里听到酒水券是在Alopecia专辑里，像Why?乐队，你知道，他做的也是同样的事情，你知道，这是你意识到的事情吗，还是我错了？我不知道，不不不，这绝对是，我的意思是，这就像治疗，你知道，就像你在电视上看到心理医生时，他们会解释你的问题是什么，但对于我所有的心理医生，我想大概有三四个，我总是对他们让我自己得出结论的方式感到失望。据我理解，那是健康的方式，因为他们不会永远
going to be around. And I think I've taken that to songwriting where I'm like, this is my experience and the specificity of the setting. Like I remember Tom Waits saying, you should always know what the weather is like in a song. And I think that you really want to let people know where the furniture is so that then they get a lay of the land and then they can reach their own conclusions because, you know, however,
陪在你身边。我想我已经把这一点带到了歌曲创作中，我想，这是我的经历，以及场景的具体性。就像我记得Tom Waits说过，你应该总是知道歌里的天气是什么样的。我认为你真的想让人们知道家具在哪里，这样他们就能了解环境，然后他们可以得出自己的结论，因为，你知道，无论如何，
people, people are in a different seat than me. And, uh, so I'm, I'm trying to go, well, this is the view from the backseat,
人们，人们坐在和我不同的位置。所以，我试图说，好吧，这是从后座看到的风景，
but you know, you might be seeing the same landscape, but you know, it's different for you. And. Well, and I'm, you're talking on the screen,
但你知道，你可能看到的是同样的风景，但你知道，对你来说是不一样的。而且。好吧，你在屏幕上说话，
but not on my audio. So I want to make sure I'm not cutting you off due to the delay. No, no, no. The, there's a little bit of a delay, so I'm trying to figure out what's going you off due to the delay no no no yeah the there's a little bit of a delay so i'm trying to figure out what's going on some of the time but the yeah and i think that's like one of the reason why writing a song in your 20s is different than writing a song in
但我的音频里没有。所以我得确保我没有因为延迟而打断你。不，不，不。有一点延迟，所以我试图弄清楚发生了什么……有一点延迟，所以我试图弄清楚发生了什么，但是的，我认为这就是为什么20多岁写歌和40多岁写歌不同的原因之一，
your 40s it's like you kind of feel like you'll have something figured out or there'll be some sort of ultimate truth at the top of the hill you know by 35 ish you're like yeah okay i'm at the top of the hill there's a couple ways down this thing but i see where it goes you know like this is kind of you know the story feels less important in a way but then that is ultimately i guess what makes the story important there's like a therapist that worked with all these famous la actors that were like all the people that went on to be famous in the 90s and the 2000s he's like real old kind of yungian guy and he had said in an interview i think with mark maron about how like he would just tell him to bring the shadow in the room they were trying not to be insecure they were trying to not look at the limitations of their performance and that made the performance flat so he was just like go in there
你觉得你已经弄明白了什么，或者在山顶会有某种终极真理，你知道，到了35岁左右，你会想，是的，好吧，我在山顶了，下山有几条路，但我看到了它通向哪里，你知道，这故事在某种程度上感觉不那么重要了，但最终这可能就是让故事变得重要的原因。有个心理医生曾为所有那些著名的洛杉矶演员工作，就是那些在90年代和2000年代成名的人，他是个很老派的荣格学派的人，他在接受Mark Maron采访时说，他会告诉他们把阴影带进房间，他们试图不表现得不安全，他们试图不去看自己表演的局限性，这让表演变得平淡，所以他只是说，进去，
and be terrified at the in the interview and that's the you know that's it and they're like no but it's a confident police sergeant he's like yeah that's boring you know, that's it. And they're like, no, but it's a confident police sergeant. He's like, yeah, that's boring. You need to be confident as a police sergeant because you're afraid. And that there's and that them taking the counterpoint to their performance made the performance work. And you kind of will do that in the songwriting a little bit, you know, like that. The stuff that feels like a trope or silly also being true. I mean, that wounded in similar ways where you say like, well, it's, it's, it's almost like, it's just some,
在采访中感到恐惧，那就是，你知道，就是这样。他们说，不，但这是一个自信的警官。他说，是的，那很无聊，你知道，就是这样。他们说，不，但这是一个自信的警官。他说，是的，那很无聊。你需要表现得自信，因为你作为警官感到害怕。而他们采取与表演相反的观点，使表演奏效了。你在歌曲创作中也会稍微做一点，你知道，就像那些感觉像是陈词滥调或愚蠢的东西，同时也可能是真实的。我的意思是，那在类似的方式下受伤，你说，好吧，它，它，它几乎就像，
it sounds like something a hippie would say, but it's also the name of the chorus of the song, you know, you're kind of like being your own, you know, writing your own, you know, YouTube review there and then responding to it in the thing in a way that becomes the song like that that's clever that's that's i don't know i mean what's your thought process there you know in those songwriting retreats everyone would say cut that hippie line out and i was like that's no that would be the exact line that vick chestnut would keep in and and even if vick
听起来像嬉皮士会说的话，但它也是歌词副歌的名字，你知道，你有点像是在做你自己的，你知道，在写你自己的YouTube评论，然后在那个东西里回应它，以一种成为歌曲的方式，这很聪明，这，我不知道，我的意思是，你那里的思维过程是什么？你知道，在那些歌曲创作静修会上，每个人都会说把那句嬉皮士的话删掉，而我说，不，那正是Vick Chesnutt会保留的那句，即使Vick
wouldn't i was like that's that's right for me i think that that's the contrast because i mean that was a and just as a footnote that was a specific line like when we were in imago couples therapy that uh she said you know mother nature has a way of matching us with people who are wounded in similar ways. And I was like, it's hard for me not to grab a pen and I would have been kicked out of it. But yeah, I think that, um, yeah, I want, uh, I want people to feel like I'm being conversational and honest with them because I feel like the, the, now I understand how,
不会，我也觉得那对我来说是对的，我认为这就是对比，因为我的意思是，那是一个，作为一个脚注，那是一句具体的台词，当我们进行Imago夫妻治疗时，她说，你知道，大自然有一种方式，把我们和那些以类似方式受伤的人匹配在一起。我当时想，我很难不拿起笔，我本来会被赶出去的。但是的，我想，嗯，我希望，我希望人们觉得我在和他们进行对话，并且对他们诚实，因为我觉得，现在我明白了，
how much a gift someone's full attention is to give to you. And so if you haven't, if you're asking them, please give me your undivided attention, uh, then I want it to be rewarding and I want them to go away going. I know what that, you know,
一个人全神贯注地倾听是多么珍贵的礼物。所以如果你没有，如果你在请求他们，请给我你全神贯注的关注，那么我希望它是值得的，我希望他们离开时会觉得，我知道那是什么，你知道，
I feel like I've got a feeling. So is, I don't know. Is that what you were saying or? Yeah, they're pretty open-ended questions. I don't know. One,
我觉得我有一种感觉。所以是，我不知道。这就是你要说的吗？是的，它们是相当开放的问题。我不知道。一个，
another question I got to ask. I, I, I'm always trying to like tune, clean these podcasts up and get them the file ready. And then I'll, I, it'll be two in the morning.
我必须问的另一个问题。我，我总是试图调整，清理这些播客，准备好文件。然后我会，我，那会是凌晨两点。
I got to go to sleep and then I get up at six and i'm taking the kids to school and be listening to the file in the car so i didn't realize my daughter was like listening to the podcast but now she started to like ask for whatever and you know she's six she doesn't know what is going on but uh i uh so she was this morning she was like i want to listen to the podcast and it's like no we can listen to your music. We don't have to do that. And she asked who the next person was. And I said, I was seeing somebody who was a singer. It wasn't just a musician. They were a singer, a songwriter, and a musician, like Taylor Swift,
我得去睡觉，然后六点起床，送孩子们上学，在车里听文件，所以我没意识到我女儿在听播客，但现在她开始要求听什么，你知道她才六岁，她不知道发生了什么，但我，我，所以今天早上她问，我想听播客，我说不，我们可以听你的音乐。我们不必那样做。她问下一个人是谁。我说，我正在见一个歌手。不仅仅是音乐家。他们是歌手、词曲作者和音乐家，就像Taylor Swift，
because that was the comparison that she understood. And I asked if she had a question. And she said, yeah, if you want to just write songs and sing them to people, how do you get money? So I said, I would ask that question of you. Yeah. yeah if you want to just write songs and sing them to people how do you get money um so i said i would ask that question of you yeah and you know which is also going to be one of my questions because that you we talk about the history of the industry artistically well a ton of the industry financially is totally different you know i mean the streaming service thing has kind of made
因为那是她能理解的比较。我问她有没有问题。她说，是的，如果你只想写歌并唱给别人听，你怎么赚钱？所以我说，我会把这个问题问你。是的，如果你只想写歌并唱给别人听，你怎么赚钱？嗯，所以我说，我会把这个问题问你。是的，你知道，这也是我的问题之一，因为我们谈论的是行业的历史，艺术上，嗯，行业的财务方面完全不同，你知道，我的意思是，流媒体服务让
everybody be permanently on tour if they want to make money. Eventbrite is your option. There's still some hipster record store holdouts, but if you are going to try and pursue it professionally, the landscape is different. Can you say anything about that or how you navigate that? There's no science or recipe or formula but i remember it makes me think of that thing that i read that kim gordon said where she said i've been amazed in my whole career as a musician how much money people will pay to watch someone on stage who believes in themselves. And I think that the, I think that the, also Paul Westerberg said, if you aim for their
每个人如果想赚钱就必须永久巡演。Eventbrite是你的选择。还有一些顽固的独立唱片店，但如果你想尝试专业追求它，环境就不同了。你能对此说些什么，或者你是如何应对的？没有科学、食谱或公式，但我记得这让我想起我读过的Kim Gordon说的话，她说，作为一名音乐家，我整个职业生涯都对人们愿意花多少钱去看一个相信自己的人在舞台上表演感到惊讶。我认为，我认为，Paul Westerberg也说过，如果你瞄准他们的
wallet, you'll miss their heart by a mile. So I think that, I think that all those, and you're talking about two of the best musicians and songwriters in the past 40 years. So I think that you just have to accept that if you're going to be completely yourself, that audience might have a limit because maybe you're a niche artist. I mean, Daniel Johnson, when he was around, he certainly wasn't for everyone, but when he spoke to people, he spoke so acutely. And so I think that your idea of money also needs to be tied to realistic expectations. Because if you are down to only be honest, then you are going to find the right people.
钱包，你会错过他们的心。所以我认为，我认为所有这些，而且你谈论的是过去40年来最好的两位音乐家和词曲作者。所以我认为你只需要接受，如果你要完全做你自己，那个受众可能会有一个限度，因为也许你是一个小众艺术家。我的意思是，Daniel Johnston，当他在世时，他当然不适合所有人，但当他与人交谈时，他谈得非常深刻。所以我认为你对金钱的看法也需要与现实的期望挂钩。因为如果你只愿意诚实，那么你就会找到合适的人。
And every dollar that they spend is going to feel like a million dollars because they will have accepted you for you. And so money becomes a very nice thing in that setting. I mean, when you see people support Dave Bazan, when he needs to buy a van and you go, that is his tribe going, that's their way of saying thank you. So that's, I'm very interested in money in that way because if,
他们花的每一美元都会感觉像一百万美元，因为他们会因为你是你而接受你。所以金钱在那种环境下会变成一件非常好的事情。我的意思是，当你看到人们支持Dave Bazan，当他需要买一辆货车时，你会想，那是他的部落在说，那是他们表达感谢的方式。所以我对金钱很感兴趣，因为如果，
if I can create art because of that, I mean, it's like I got paid for working at a pizzeria, you know, because I worked hard. And if I work hard at being honest and being vulnerable, then if that's rewarded commiserately by the right people, then I'm all for it. And, and and it just that comes with time, you know. Well, and I think the the cultural space that music fills, it's coming back as one of the only outlets for often authentic, not celebrity, but like authentic public persona, you know, like, you know, YouTube and everything was kind of conceived of as well everybody will have a voice and you know it won't you know what is it that um andy whirl had said that you know the everybody in the future will have their 15 minutes of fame there won't be celebrity um as these cameras shrink and all that but then it kind of turned into the people who are big who make money they
如果我能因此创作艺术，我的意思是，这就像我在披萨店工作拿工资一样，你知道，因为我努力工作了。如果我努力做到诚实和脆弱，那么如果这能得到合适的人的相应回报，那么我完全支持。而且，这需要时间，你知道。好吧，我认为音乐填补的文化空间，它正在回归，作为通常真实的、非名人的、但像真实的公共形象的唯一出口之一，你知道，你知道，YouTube和所有东西都被构想为每个人都会有声音，你知道它不会，你知道Andy Warhol说过，未来每个人都会有15分钟的成名时间，不会有名人，随着这些摄像机缩小等等，但后来它变成了那些赚大钱的大人物，他们
can't have a personality you know like i that i'm too old for it but it's like mr beast or one of these people that is one of the younger you know gen z influence or something said something about how like i can never say anything about myself or anything like i have to talk like i don't i want to have nothing i don't even want to know what who i am was essentially what he said in order to be maybe a millionaire at you know 20 and it's like oh that's you know these those algorithms have ripped all of that out of it and you know i think politics used to be something that people kind of saw i mean it's arguably largely been fake in my lifetime but i mean no one even is sort of pretending that right left is not just a
不能有个性，你知道，我太老了，不适合这个，但就像MrBeast或这些年轻的Z世代网红中的某个人说了一些关于“我永远不能说任何关于我自己的事，或者任何事，我必须说话，就像我不想有任何东西，我甚至不想知道我是谁”，本质上就是他所说的，为了在20岁时成为百万富翁，这就像，哦，那是，你知道，那些算法已经把所有这些都从里面撕掉了，你知道，我认为政治过去是人们某种程度上看到的东西，我的意思是，在我的一生中，它在很大程度上可以说是假的，但我的意思是，甚至没有人假装左右之争不仅仅是一场
performance you know it it looks weirder and faker than it ever has. And I think singer, songwriter, musician, I mean, there's kind of a rap feud going on right now. It seems like one of the only places where you can see a real authentic person doing a thing,
表演，你知道，它看起来比以往任何时候都更奇怪、更虚假。我认为歌手、词曲作者、音乐家，我的意思是，现在有一种说唱争斗正在进行。这似乎是你可以看到一个真实的人在做一件事的唯一地方之一，
um, and any kind of part of our culture. Now, I don't know if you feel that or, or dialogue with that, but it does seem like a trend. Yeah. Yeah.
嗯，以及我们文化的任何部分。现在，我不知道你是否感觉到，或者与此对话，但这确实看起来是一个趋势。是的。是的。
And I think that it was, it was gobsmacking that, uh, when Kendrick wrote that verse, just about like to Drake's son, I was like, Whoa, because that is so,
而且我认为，当Kendrick写下那段关于Drake儿子的歌词时，真是令人震惊，我当时想，哇，因为那太，
uh, so it's so, uh, so it's so, uh, it made me feel strongly, you know, it made me feel strongly that that is such a stance. And it, I mean, it's like Jeff Koons, it's like art. It's like going, whoa, that is hard. And so while the right and the wrong of it certainly is debatable, I thought in that way, Kendrick was going, I don't care to be on the cover of the magazines. He goes, I like, he goes, I'm not trying to be everything to everyone. And I, and yeah, so I, it's,
嗯，太，嗯，太，嗯，它让我感觉强烈，你知道，它让我强烈地感觉到那是一个立场。而且，我的意思是，它就像Jeff Koons，它就像艺术。就像说，哇，那很硬。所以虽然它的对错当然是有争议的，但我认为在那种方式上，Kendrick是在说，我不在乎上杂志封面。他说，我喜欢，他说，我不是试图成为所有人的所有东西。而且，是的，所以，它，
it really is interesting how the more you lean into yourself, you, it's also a risky thing because you can become self-indulgent, lose objectivity. But I think that you do, I think that you do tread the line of you know flirting with narcissism because you're trying to really understand where you're coming from and that so you know it's it's it's just a it's a balance and it's a balance that, you know, it's like you can tread a tightrope when you're young and thin, but then when you get older and you've got weight and you don't have as good a balance and you're on a tightrope, it's like you can never quite get rid of it you know it's almost always on its way out because it's always changing but there's something about the archetype of the
当你越倾向于自己时，这确实很有趣，这也是一件冒险的事情，因为你可能会变得自我放纵，失去客观性。但我认为你确实，我认为你确实走在你知道与自恋调情的边缘，因为你试图真正理解你来自哪里，所以你知道，它，它，它只是一个平衡，这是一个平衡，你知道，就像你年轻瘦弱时可以在钢丝上行走，但当你变老了，有了重量，平衡感没那么好了，你在钢丝上，就像你永远无法摆脱它，你知道，它几乎总是在消失，因为它总是在变化，但关于那种
authentic poet speaking truth to power or the other poet or you know you channeling the culture that singer-songwriter as a tradition is pretty close to that you know in the same way hip-hop maybe is you know um yeah how do you create you're creating your own radio station where people go well i'm not always tuning into 88.5 but i feel like 88.5 right now and that's each of our as songwriters that's our radio station like i mean not always 88.5 but just where you go i'm coming to this guy or girl or you know i'm coming to this songwriter for that reason and that is that is incumbent upon every songwriter to have that definite reason you did it's not definite genre but you go i come to this person for this well and uh you know you've come over and over again to the idea of asking
真实的诗人向权力说真话，或者另一个诗人，或者你知道，你引导文化，那种作为传统的创作歌手非常接近这一点，你知道，就像嘻哈音乐可能是一样，你知道，嗯，是的，你是如何创造你自己的广播电台的，人们会说，我并不总是调到88.5，但我现在感觉像88.5，作为词曲作者，那是我们每个人的广播电台，就像，我的意思是，不总是88.5，只是你去的地方，我来找这个男人或女人，或者你知道，我来找这个词曲作者是因为那个原因，而每个词曲作者都有责任有那个明确的原因，你做到了，这不是明确的流派，但你会说，我来找这个人是为了这个。好吧，而且，你知道，你一次又一次地回到询问
for permission that you're not even aware of you know where you're asking for permission to do something that you can just do and that you're better off if you just do it you know and that you kind of confronted that with your looking at your older songs and looking at the um lyrics at the songwriting camp and different in therapy you mentioned it um and it's a big question but do you know what it is that you're wanting to say you know do you know what it is that you're trying to have permission to do you know as a as a project you know what is is what is the nature of your art or you're kind of you're you're not not met not that it has to be a message um but you what, what you're getting at in a way that someone else is getting at
许可的想法，你甚至没有意识到，你知道，你在请求许可去做一些你本来就可以做的事情，而且如果你直接去做，你会更好，你知道，而且你在看你的老歌和看歌曲创作营的歌词以及在治疗中提到它时，你面对了这一点，嗯，这是一个大问题，但你知道你想说什么吗？你知道你试图请求许可去做什么吗？作为一个项目，你知道，你的艺术本质是什么，或者你，你，你不是，不是说它必须是一个信息，但你，你试图达到的东西，以一种别人正在达到
a different thing. I think it's belonging. I think that it's, it's you, you want to be well-read. So you want to find other people who are well-read. So you want to put it out that, you know, you want to put it out there that I will want to, it out there that i want to i want to have a beer or coffee with people who are well read i want to be in that company but then you go well am i being pretentious when i you know when i throw out that magnet of being well read and so it's constantly like you're you get that i have have many leather bound books vibe that,
不同东西的方式。我认为是归属感。我认为，它是，你，你想博学。所以你想找到其他博学的人。所以你想把它放出来，你知道，你想把它放出来，我想和博学的人喝啤酒或咖啡，我想在那样的公司里，但然后你会想，当我抛出那个博学的磁铁时，我是不是在装模作样？所以它不断地就像你得到了那种“我有许多皮装书”的氛围，
you know, a lot of YouTube. I guess moleskins are good enough for you. Where, where is this? Like you, like today's a perfect example, you know,
你知道，很多YouTube。我想Moleskine笔记本对你来说足够好了。这是在哪里？就像你，就像今天就是一个完美的例子，你知道，
like that's why it is. It was a pleasure. Like it's not lost time when we lost those few minutes recording because it was like, you're exactly like, I would insist that we go to dinner if I came to Birmingham. Yeah. And so that's, that's, that's what you're trying to do. You're trying to build your community of, of people who make you feel like you belong. And I think that, I think that you can be insecure because you can
这就是为什么它是。这是一种荣幸。当我们浪费那几分钟录音时，那不是浪费时间，因为就像，你完全就像，如果我来到伯明翰，我会坚持我们要去吃晚饭。是的，所以这就是，这就是你试图做的。你试图建立你的社区，那些让你觉得你有归属感的人。而且我认为，我认为你可以不安全，因为你可以
you know the the more honest and vulnerable you be the brighter your light shines like that that it's so and it's a threat in some ways you know people hear something that they want to call um well i think that that vulnerability and authenticity is what other people are going to attack as pretentious, you know, and then as an artist, you're always vulnerable and insecure that that is pretension, that it isn't really real, that it's somehow a performance of the self and not the real self. And so is this actually how I feel? Yeah. And so you have to get over that fear of you're going to get that message. There's somebody in the room that's going to say, who are you to say that? Do you have a right to say that you're not really saying that you got this from somewhere else?
你知道，你越诚实和脆弱，你的光芒就越明亮，就像那样，而且在某些方面这是一种威胁，你知道，人们听到他们想称之为……嗯，我认为那种脆弱和真实是其他人会攻击为装模作样的东西，你知道，然后作为艺术家，你总是脆弱和不安全，认为那是装模作样，它不是真的，它在某种程度上是对自我的表演，而不是真实的自我。所以这真的是我的感受吗？是的。所以你必须克服那种你会收到那种信息的恐惧。房间里会有人说，你算什么？你有权说你不是真的在说吗？你从别处得到的这个？
It isn't yours. I mean, that's just going to be the voice of the critic at some point. And you have to have some kind of greater principle of faith or self that takes you through that before you can really get it out. I think I work with a lot of, I mean, I work with a lot of artists in different professions and even,
它不是你的。我的意思是，那在某个时候只会是评论家的声音。你必须有某种更大的信仰原则或自我，带你度过那个阶段，然后你才能真正把它表达出来。我想我和很多，我的意思是，我和很多不同职业的艺术家一起工作，甚至，
you know, business can be an art in a certain way. Sometimes, you know, people authentically, you know, I just work in that process of self and development. And that's kind of the pattern I see over and over again is that people kind
你知道，商业在某种程度上可以是一种艺术。有时，你知道，人们真实地，你知道，我只是在那个自我和发展的过程中工作。这就是我一次又一次看到的模式，人们某种程度上
of weigh the pros and cons. And when they get to a place where they're like, yeah, you know, of course they're going to say that. And I don't care. And that's when the thing hits and all of a sudden lightning strikes and you've got the next thing yeah yeah and it's it's a it's a weird sentiment but it's like uh you know you're doing something
权衡利弊。当他们到达一个地方，他们想，是的，你知道，他们当然会那样说。我不在乎。那就是事情发生的时候，突然闪电击中，你就有了下一件事。是的，是的，这是一种奇怪的情绪，但就像，嗯，你知道，当你有了黑粉时，你做对了某事，因为你在引发反应，而且我认为只要你不是为了得到反应而做，那么反应是可以的，只要你不是为了得到反应而做，那么反应是可以的，但如果你是为了得到反应而做，也许是因为你在反应，如果你在反应，并且你弄清楚了你为什么反应，那是一个想法，但如果你在说某事，我的意思是，并不是说反应就不那么真实，因为，我的意思是，我们都在对某事做出反应。但这只是很有趣，嗯，我们如何去做的追求，你知道，什么，你为什么要让自己经历所有这些艺术，就像，嗯，我和我妻子关于花在创作艺术上的钱的争吵，以及我演出的没人来的演出数量。以及我花在早上6点微调歌词上的时间，或者就像有一首歌
right when you've got haters because you are provoking a reaction and i think that as long as you're not doing it to get a reaction then the reaction's okay long as you're not doing it to get a reaction then the reaction is okay but if if you're doing it to get a reaction maybe it's because you are reacting and if you're reacting and you're making sense of why you reacted that's an idea uh but if you're saying something i mean not that reacting isn't just as authentic because, I mean, we're all reacting to, you know, one thing or another. But it's just interesting the, yeah, the pursuit of how we go about, you know, what, why would you put yourself through all this art, like the amount of, uh, bites, you know, my wife and I've had about money spent on creating art and the amount of shows that I've played that no one came to. And the amount of hours that I spend at 6.00 AM fine tuning the lyric or like there was a song
在这张专辑里没能入选。而且，我敢打赌我经历了40个不同版本的歌词，不是小的改动，是重大的改动，在那一点上你会想，我做错了什么，因为我试图让它完美，而且我的意思是，我不知道是谁说的，但就像没有艺术是完成的，它只是被放弃了，所以是的，或者它是吗？我想，嗯，是达芬奇关于石雕说的吗？它只是在好的地方停下来了，或者类似的东西，你知道，我喜欢那个，是的，是的，那很好，是的，那非常好，你永远，永远没有完成，是的，我的意思是，关于这张专辑，有什么我们还没涉及到的歌词吗？我的意思是，你必须逐字逐句地走过每一首歌词，似乎，嗯，像也许不是，你知道，在采访中问艺术家的一件公平的事情，但像是有你想谈论的地方吗，你知道，它，
on this album that didn't make it. And I, I bet bet you i went through 40 different versions of lyrics not not minor changes significant changes and at that point you're like i'm doing something wrong because i'm trying to make it perfect and i mean i don't know who said it but it's like no art has ever uh completed it's just abandoned so yeah or is it i think um was it da vinci that was about stone carving said it like it just stopped in nice places or something um you know i like that yeah yeah that's good yeah that's very good that you're never uh never finished yeah i mean is there anything about the album that we haven't gotten into as far as lyrics i mean you've got to just kind of walk through every song lyric by lyric seems um like maybe not uh you know a fair thing to ask the artist in an interview but like are there places that you want to talk about that uh you know it's
它，这些歌都非常不同，你知道，但它们挂在一起。我很高兴还有人把专辑当作一个项目来制作。谢谢。我认为在《Heart Decides》里有一句歌词，它说，关于某某爱上了某某，所以A爱上了B，B爱上了C，但C爱上了某某，以此类推，就像A爱上了B，B爱上了C，但C爱上了他自己，而那正是启动整个事情的情绪，它只是关于我在悉尼住了10年时的那三个人，所以我就拿了那个情绪，仅仅那个情绪就像牡蛎里的沙粒。我就让它，是什么，孕育，随着时间推移而酝酿？
a it the songs are all very different you know but they hang. I'm glad that somebody's still making albums as a project. Thank you. I think that there's a lyric in Heart Decides where it says, where it's something about so-and-so was in love with so-and-so, and so A was in love with B, and B was in love with C, but C was in love with so-and-so and so on like a was in love with b and b was in love with c but c was in love with him with himself and that was the sentiment that launched that whole thing and it was just about these three people in australia when i lived down in sydney for 10 years and so then i took that that sentiment and just that one sentiment was just the piece of sand in the oyster. And I just let it, what is it, gestate, gestulate over time?
我就让它成为它需要成为的样子。然后我试着把它联系起来。我做了很多物体写作，就像写日记关于一种情绪，只是为了找出我的立场，关于那种情绪是什么触动了我的心弦。但像那样的东西，你把专辑按时间顺序排列很有趣，因为你真的在以某种顺序了解某人。而那样，我希望我没有把第一首歌放在第一位，就像先让某人进来。我希望我，就像那首歌，它，我最初写那首歌像《Glad Girls》来自《God About Voices, Isolation Drills》。它就像，不是让某人进来，而是每个人都进来，它就像一个俱乐部，每个人，它保持，就像俱乐部扩大了，有每个，保镖就像每个人都进来，它就像关于，可能关于归属感，但后来我想，我不知道，而且我，但我希望它在那个之间，然后在那个和John Prine的《Way Down》之间。它来自那张上面有画的白色专辑，白色的。总之，但是的，成年人。我有一天在刮胡子，那确实发生了，我开了一个我认为很微妙的玩笑。
I just let it become what it needed to become. And then I tried to tie it in. I do a lot of object writing, like journaling just about a sentiment, just to find out where I stand, what it is about that sentiment that rings my bell. But stuff like that, it's interesting how you put an album in chronological order because you're really getting to know someone in a certain order. And in that way, I wish I wouldn't have put the first song first, like let somebody in first. I wish I would have, like with that song, it was, I initially wrote that song like Glad
他说，谦虚地。我妻子笑了，我想我可以，我说，我永远不能和一个愚蠢的人结婚。她说，这不容易。所以是的，
Girls from God About Voices, Isolation Drills. It was like, instead of let somebody in it was like everyone gets in and it was like a club where everyone it keeps like the club expands and there was every the bouncers were like everyone gets in it was like about probably about belonging but then i was like i don't know and i but i wanted it to be between that and then between that and John Prine's Way Down. It's off the white album with the drawing on it, the white. Anyway, but yeah, grown man. I was shaving one day, and that actually happened that I made a joke that I thought was subtle.
它，我试图从这些东西中汲取。我希望我没有退缩。我没说愚蠢。我说的是愚蠢的（foolish）。我想“愚蠢”（stupid）落地时发出了沉闷的声音，但我希望我说了那个，所以是的，好吧，我的意思是，我认为当球开始滚动时，上一张专辑的遗憾就变成了下一张专辑，你知道，然后这就是，当你真正接触到一个艺术项目时，有一种，我的意思是，三个
He said, modestly. And my wife laughed and I thought I could, and I said, I could never be married to someone stupid. She was like, it's not easy. So yeah,
我看到的创意人员的路线之一是，你永远不快乐，但你永远不痛苦，因为你在处理它。但也包括你现在正在做的事情，你并不真正关心，因为它完成了，它的缺点或者它未能表达的东西，对吧，变成了下一件事，你知道，
it's, I'm trying to draw from the stuff. I wish I wouldn't have chickened out. I didn't say stupid. I said foolish. And I thought stupid lands was such a thud but i wish i would have said that so yeah well i mean i i think when the ball gets rolling the the regrets from the last album become the next album you know and then that's what there's sort of a when you're really in touch with an artistic project i mean one of the three
而且它有一种动力。它就像，嗯，活塞和火车引擎，你知道，它总是前后移动，但你永远没有真正完成。有一个过程。这就是为什么我喜欢，每次我去吃晚饭
lines i see with creatives is that you're never happy, but you're never unhappy because you're working on it. But also the thing that you're doing right now, you don't really care about because it's done and the faults with it or the thing it failed to say, right. Become the next thing, you know,
我都会试着给在那里的每个人拍张照片。它不会是一张完美的照片。总会有人对他们在照片里的样子不满意，但那是一首歌。你只是在捕捉时间里的某样东西。它不是决定性的。就像，我认为很多人会想，哦，不是很多人。我想我过去认为一首歌会定义这个主题。但它不会。它描述了一个主题的一个方面，但没有，没有四分钟、六分钟的歌能完全概括你对一个
and there's this momentum to it. It's like the, uh, piston and the train engine, you know, that's kind of always going backwards and forwards, but you're never quite done. There's a process. And that's why I love, every time I go to dinner
主题的感受。就像我的家乡是一个很好的例子，就像Bruce Springsteen，现象级的歌，很棒的贯穿线，但他谈论的是他的家乡。我的意思是，他触及了他父亲的事实，
I try and take a photo of everyone that was there. It's not going to be a perfect photo. Someone's always going to be unhappy about how they looked in it, but that's a song. You're just capturing something in time. It's not definitive. Like, I think a lot of people go, oh, not a lot of people. I think that I used to think one song is going to define this one subject. And it doesn't. it describes an aspect of a subject, but it no, no one four minutes, six minute song is going to encapsulate exactly how you feel about one
他坐在他父亲的膝盖上，但这并没有说明他和父亲的关系是什么样的，他妈妈没被提到，他的兄弟姐妹也没被提到，你知道，这只是他与家乡的关系。而且它看起来像一个，它概括了他的生活，但它只是非常彻底地概括了他生活的一个方面。而且他可以离开，写另一个版本的，你知道，在二垒打球的感受，在他的家乡。而那只是充实了，
subject. Like my hometown is a great example of like Bruce Springsteen, phenomenal song, great, great through line, but he's talking about his hometown. I mean, he touches on the fact that his dad,
照片，背景。而且你，嗯，当，当你，嗯，你有什么像，因为你也工作，你还有另一份工作
he was sitting on his dad's lap but that doesn't spell out what his relationship was like with his dad his mom's not mentioned his siblings aren't you know it's just his relationship to his hometown and it seems like a it encapsulates his life but it just encapsulates very thoroughly one aspect of his life. And he can go away and write another version of light, what it was like to be on the, you know, play in second base in his hometown. And that just fleshes out the,
就像你，你工作，嗯，你，我们，当我们给你发邮件时，你说你有别的东西，你对工作与生活的平衡有什么看法吗？因为所有，我想所有我看到的创作歌手或所有音乐家都在某种程度上为此挣扎，他们让你，你知道，在什么点上我，你知道，我可以辞掉我的工作，或者我，你知道，我可以辞掉我的工作？或者我想我永远无法真正辞掉我的工作，因为我在说我想说的话。而且它有，而且它已经成功了，但有一个限制，有多少人会在不让我淡化它的情况下得到它。我的意思是，成为一个，你知道，是专业音乐家同时也是专业其他什么东西的过程，有什么对你来说有趣的地方吗，还是那都只是无聊的、不好玩的部分？嗯，我想，我想，嗯，拥有
the photo, the background. And do you, um, when, when you, uh, do you have anything like, cause you you also work you have another job too
一份工作很好，因为我认为仅仅为了写歌，你需要离开，不去想歌，而且我认为平衡是，如果你是什么，我想我妻子告诉我，在你被工作拥有之前，你能赚多少钱有一个最佳点。我想大概是在110到175之间，这是，你知道，一个我怀疑我会触及的平流层。但它是其中之一，如果你能找到一份工作并做到这一点，早上在去往某件你不想做的事情的路上听音乐很重要。因为事物有这种二元性，你开车时并没有完全集中在歌上。所以你只是在吸收它，在那些你开车时并没有完全集中在歌上，所以你只是，你只是在吸收它，你知道，在背景里，当你打开你的，你知道，转向灯等等，而且你也有更少的压力，我的意思是，我会独自去吃午饭
like you you work um you had we were when we were emailing you and said you got another stuff do you have anything about the work-life balance of it because all i think all the singer-songwriters or all the musicians that i see kind of struggle with that that they make you know like at what point do i you know can i quit my job or i do I, you know, can I quit my job? Or I guess I'll never really be able to quit my job because I'm saying the thing I want to say. And it has, and it's gotten successful, but that there's a limit on how many people are going to get that without me watering it down. I mean, that process of being somebody who, you know, is a professional musician and also a professional else anything interesting to you there is that all just kind of the the boring not fun part uh i think i think that um it's good to have
很多次，只是在一个我通常不会去的地方写作。我会在圣安东尼奥。所以我认为这很好。我几年前当然没有那种感觉，当时我对自己的创造力和音乐感到非常沮丧。但后来有一个中间地带，如果你能聪明地对待你所做的事情，我在建筑业工作，我的心并没有，不需要把心放在里面。这留下了很多空闲时间，当我回家时，我的精神没有被征税，我可以写作。而且，嗯，然后你到了需要演出的时候。你需要站在人们面前，因为那是它自己的，仅仅因为你能写歌。并不意味着你擅长表演歌曲。即使是你写的，你知道，就像你，你听到人们做现象级的。
a job because i think that just to write songs you need to go away and not think about songs and i think the balance is if you're what was it that I think my wife was telling me that there's a sweet spot of how much money you can make before your job owns you. And I think it was like maybe between like 110 to 175, which is, you know, a stratosphere that I doubt I'll be flirting with. But it's one of those, if you can find a job and do that, it's important to wake up and listen to music in the morning on the way to something that you don't want to do. Because there's this duality of things where you're driving and you're not fully concentrated on the song. And so you're just absorbing it in the things where you're driving and you're not fully concentrated on the song and so you're just you're just absorbing it you know in the background while you're turning on your you know turn signal and whatnot and you also have less pressure i mean you i would go to lunch by myself
一份工作，因为我觉得要写歌，你需要抽离出来，不去想歌曲本身。我觉得平衡点在于，我妻子曾告诉我，在你的工作完全占据你之前，有一个收入的“甜蜜点”。我想大概是在11万到17.5万之间，这对我来说是一个遥不可及的领域。但如果你能找到一份工作并做到这一点，这很重要，比如早上在去往某个你并不想去的地方的路上听音乐。因为这有一种二元性，你开车时并没有完全专注于歌曲，所以你只是在背景中吸收它，同时还要打转向灯之类的。而且你的压力也更小，我是说，我会独自去吃午饭
a lot and just do writing in a in a place that i normally wouldn't be. I'd be in San Antonio. And so I think it's good. I certainly didn't feel that years ago when I felt so frustrated with my own creativity and music. But then there's that middle ground where if you can be smart about what you do, where I worked in construction and my heart didn't, it wasn't required to have my heart in it. And that left a lot of free time where I wasn't mentally taxed when I came
经常这样，就在我平时不会去的地方写歌。我会在圣安东尼奥。所以我认为这很好。几年前我对自己创造力和音乐感到非常沮丧时，肯定没有这种感觉。但中间有一个平衡点，如果你能聪明地处理工作，比如我曾在建筑工地工作，我的心并不需要投入其中。这留出了很多空闲时间，当我回家时，我的精神并没有感到疲惫
home where I could write. And, uh, and then you get to the point where you need to play shows. You need to be in front of people because that is its own, just cause you can write songs. Doesn't mean you're good at performing songs. Even if you wrote them, you know, like you, you hear people do phenomenal.
我可以写歌。然后，当你到了需要演出的时候，你需要站在观众面前，因为那是另一回事。仅仅因为你能写歌，并不意味着你擅长表演歌曲。即使是你自己写的，你知道，就像你听到别人唱得非常棒一样。
I mean, Jeff Buckley did a phenomenal cover of hallelujah. And, um, that's, that's where songs take on a new form when you, you can play them live in front of people and you get past the nerves. And I mean, Coltrane's always used to say, I practice eight hours a week, six days a week, eight hours a day, six hours a week. So that when I'm playing,
我的意思是，杰夫·巴克利（Jeff Buckley）翻唱的《哈利路亚》（Hallelujah）非常出色。嗯，这就是歌曲在现场表演、面对观众并克服紧张情绪后，呈现出新形式的地方。我的意思是，科尔特兰（Coltrane）总是说，我每周练习六天，每天八小时，每周六小时。这样当我演奏时，
I'm not thinking it's second nature. And, and it does help to get into different rooms, different cities, because then you go, I have gone out of my way. I'm not with my family. And I certainly work hard to have that balance. I mean, I don't play a lot of shows because my wife is my priority,
我不需要思考，这已经成为第二天性。而且，去不同的城市、不同的场地确实有帮助，因为你会想，我为了这些付出了很多。我没和家人在一起。我当然努力工作以保持这种平衡。我的意思是，我不会参加很多演出，因为我的妻子是我的首要任务，
but it is vitally important to play shows and to get out of your comfort zones and to remind yourself that it's a discipline. And if you're going to go and drive three hours to play a show, you believe in what you're saying and you believe that it's worth someone's time. And so it's just, you're in different stages and just enjoy the stage that you're in. Well, that's beautiful. That's probably a great place to leave it. I want to be respectful of your time and not go too far over anything that we'll definitely link to your SoundCloud and your website in the show notes. Is there anything else that you'd like to talk about
但进行现场表演、走出舒适区并提醒自己这是一种纪律是非常重要的。如果你愿意开车三个小时去参加一场演出，说明你相信自己所表达的内容，也相信这值得别人花时间去听。所以，你处于不同的阶段，享受你所处的阶段就好。嗯，那太美好了。这可能是一个很好的结束点。我想尊重你的时间，不想占用太多，我们肯定会在节目说明中附上你的 SoundCloud 和网站链接。还有什么你想谈谈
or encourage people to look up? No, I think it. The, the only thing I'd say is because this is about like therapy, like the, the, the premise of your podcast. Well, it kind of becomes the psychology of, you know, weird stuff, which is sort of the, I just didn't have it in my, uh, in my, I had no ability to have a podcast where once a week I was like, here's the 10 mindfulness tips to, you know, we're just talking about art and design and, you know, peeling the meat off your soul and talking directly to God and all of the, you know, strange mystical things out there. So that's kind of our niche. It's funny that you can get to something directly in an indirect way. Like I've, uh, I've, I'm editing my own, uh, podcast that I'm about to be coming out with called talking singles, drinking doubles, where it's, it's, you're talking about a single piece of art, whether it be a single song or a single painting, or even a single approach as a window into how one individual piece of art works and so that like that's why it meant a lot joel when you said like you like the songs but
或者鼓励大家去了解的吗？不，我想……我唯一想说的是，因为这关于心理治疗，就像你播客的前提一样。嗯，它有点变成了某种奇怪事物的心理学，也就是，我只是没有能力做一个每周分享“10个正念技巧”之类的播客，你知道，我们只是在谈论艺术和设计，你知道，剥开灵魂的表象，直接与上帝对话，以及所有那些奇怪的神秘事物。所以这就是我们的定位。有趣的是，你可以通过间接的方式直接触及某些东西。比如，我正在剪辑我即将推出的播客，叫《谈论单曲，畅饮双份》（Talking Singles, Drinking Doubles），它是关于谈论单一的艺术作品，无论是单曲、单幅画作，甚至是一种单一的方法，以此作为洞察单个艺术作品如何运作的窗口。所以，乔尔，这就是为什么当你提到你喜欢这些歌时，对我意义重大，因为
they're all different because i like the album's out now on spot, but I'm going to be still releasing the songs individually with their own artwork, because I want people to see each individual piece standalone. So you go, you walked in and you heard this song. Would you go, that's my guy because that's how lines stand. And so I think that,
它们各不相同。因为我喜欢现在的专辑在 Spotify 上线，但我仍会单独发布这些歌曲，并配上各自的艺术作品，因为我希望人们能看到每一件作品的独立性。所以你会想，你走进来听了这首歌，你会说，这就是我喜欢的风格，因为这就是它独立存在的方式。所以我认为，
I think it's cool the way that you do it because it lets it take its own shape, the conversation. But it's, yeah, just the importance of saying, yeah, saying what you want to say in one thing and how that drills down to therapy or acceptance. Yeah. And do you, was there anything in your history with therapy that was kind of interesting to you or even as a, even as a question or an open ended, you know, just as a conversation? Cause I think,
我觉得你这种方式很酷，因为它让对话呈现出它自己的形状。但确实，重要的是要说出你想在某件事中表达的东西，以及这如何深入到心理治疗或接纳。是的。在你过去的心理治疗经历中，有什么让你觉得有趣的事情吗？或者作为一个问题，或者一个开放式的对话？因为我觉得，
I mean, a part of my project with this and probably with taproot is to kind of reclaim psychology as this part of life and art and growth and design. And like, yes, we do state of the art trauma treatment we do a lot of things that you cannot get anywhere else in the state of alabama but that you don't have to be a wounded hurt puppy to go to therapy it's not like oh there's something wrong with you come here you know and i i want even you know there's nothing
我的意思是，我这个项目的一部分，可能也包括 Taproot，是想重新定义心理学，将其视为生活、艺术、成长和设计的一部分。是的，我们提供最先进的创伤治疗，我们做很多你在阿拉巴马州其他任何地方都得不到的事情，但你不需要成为一个受伤的小狗才能去接受心理治疗。这不像是在说“哦，你出了什么问题，快过来”，你知道，我甚至想说，没有什么
wrong with you if you're traumatized um you know, and kind of letting us see the humanity. Maybe I can't get rid of the liberal arts education, but then music and psychology and the artists that are and architects and all that stuff. And I think when you lose that, there's a problem. Yeah. Go ahead. Yeah. Yeah. My friend Sally, her mom had has been in therapy her whole life
如果你受过创伤，你有什么问题。嗯，你知道，让我们看到人性。也许我无法摆脱文科教育的影响，但音乐、心理学、艺术家、建筑师等等，所有这些东西。我认为当你失去这些时，就会出现问题。是的。请继续。是的。是的。我的朋友萨莉，她的妈妈一生都在接受心理治疗，
and uh and then sally goes i i just feel like going for a tune-up you know like a three or four months just to work through things and that's how i would view it like financially if we got more on our feet you know i'd like to when we went into a maga therapy um it was good because you you have another person keeping you honest and it's so so interesting if you if you feel uh you're open to hearing hard truths about yourself, boy, that accelerates your growth because then you're going, this person, you're perceiving it this way, but that's not the way it was. And I mean, heaven, I'm so fortunate because my wife is such an objective and positive influence and thinker on my life and very leads with her heart
然后萨莉说，我只是觉得需要去“调理”一下，你知道，就像三四个月一次，只是为了理清思绪。这就是我的看法。如果我们在经济上更宽裕一些，你知道，我想当我们进行心理治疗时，这很好，因为你有另一个人让你保持诚实。如果你愿意听关于自己的残酷真相，这真的会加速你的成长，因为你会想，这个人，你以这种方式感知它，但事实并非如此。我的意思是，天哪，我太幸运了，因为我的妻子对我的人生有着客观且积极的影响，她是一个思想者，总是用心去引导，
and cares. And so, you know, I think that it's, yeah, I think that having a clear mind, I think also, I think it opened my eyes where when you go to therapy, you don't come out necessarily happy. You come out with a clearer mind and your expectations on life are a lot more realistic. And it doesn't mean that the things that triggered you... The growth is grief. You're really accepting something that you wish was not there, but it is there. And your emotional reactions to it are not helping you make it disappear because it's life. And somebody who says, hey, this is not going to go away, but you can become bigger than that is something that too much therapy has has stared away from doing. And it made people dependent on the therapist and it made therapy more simplistic and mechanistic than it should be, I think.
并且关心他人。所以，你知道，我认为，是的，我认为拥有一个清醒的头脑很重要。我也认为，这让我大开眼界，当你去接受心理治疗时，你并不一定会变得快乐。你得到的是一个更清醒的头脑，你对生活的期望会变得更加现实。这并不意味着那些触发你的事情……成长就是悲伤。你真的在接纳一些你希望不存在但确实存在的东西。而你对它的情绪反应并不能帮你让它消失，因为这就是生活。有人说，嘿，这不会消失，但你可以变得比它更强大，这是太多心理治疗所回避的事情。我认为这让人们依赖治疗师，并使心理治疗变得比它本应有的更简单、更机械。
Yeah. And even if therapy just sets you 50% more free, how, like when, when do you think would be the right time to get that 50% back? Yeah. Yeah. So you're, you're in Austin right now.
是的。即使心理治疗只是让你多获得50%的自由，你觉得什么时候是找回那50%的最佳时机呢？是的。是的。所以你现在在奥斯汀，
Is that right? Yeah. Yeah. The emotional transformation therapies. That's like one of the only places that you can get it consistently. Uh, ETT. Uh,
对吗？是的。是的。情绪转化疗法（ETT）。那是少数几个能持续获得这种治疗的地方之一。嗯，ETT。嗯，
and then brain spotting is also another one that we do. But they're both, they sound cranky as hell. Like I wouldn't have believed any of it if I hadn't done it. And then, you know, now like I'm so fascinated by the science just because it took months for people, for me to just be like, all right, this thing works. This is 100% replicatable, but why?
还有脑点疗法（Brain spotting）也是我们做的另一种。但它们听起来都非常古怪。如果我没亲身体验过，我根本不会相信。然后，你知道，现在我对其中的科学原理非常着迷，因为人们花了好几个月的时间，才让我觉得，好吧，这东西真的有效。这是100%可复制的，但为什么呢？
You know, but they're both using visual stimuli to kind of skip the front and largely the middle of the brain i mean you're going through all these emotional reactions that you don't even have to know what they are and if anything comes back it usually is kind of later um it more is a felt thing and then the memory comes back later um but artists and creators uh so they're they're both different ett uses three things like really specific there's these machines that make really specific uh color uh and light blink rate frequencies and then the direction of the light on the pupil to do something to the occipital and then brain spotting uses eye position um like you have a pointer and it's just finding a spot where you the therapist sees a bizarre pupil dilation that reflects that there there's some parasympathetic
你知道，但它们都使用视觉刺激来跳过大脑的前部和大部分中部。我的意思是，你正在经历所有这些你甚至不需要知道是什么的情绪反应。如果有什么东西浮现出来，通常也是在稍后。嗯，它更多是一种感觉，然后记忆才会随之而来。但艺术家和创作者……所以它们两者不同。ETT 使用三样东西，非常具体。有这些机器可以产生非常具体的颜色、光线闪烁频率，以及光线在瞳孔上的方向，从而对枕叶产生作用。而脑点疗法使用眼球位置，就像你有一个指针，它只是在寻找一个点，治疗师会看到奇怪的瞳孔放大，这反映出神经系统存在某种副交感神经
and sympathetic activation of the nervous system but basically what both of them do is they're finding a place where your parasympathetic primitive parasympathetic and sympathetic nervous system are trying to handle the same emotion in two different paradoxical ways so you can't go through the emotion and you're kind of stuck and you're popping that, which releases a lot of somatic and kind of icky emotional energy. And then two, three days later, a lot of time, if you're going to remember what that thing is, it pops up. I mean, what, for me, I was like, I just felt so vulnerable and kind of angry for like two days. And then when I was just done and
和交感神经的激活。但基本上它们所做的都是在寻找一个地方，你的原始副交感神经和交感神经系统正试图以两种不同的矛盾方式处理同一种情绪，所以你无法通过这种情绪，你被卡住了。而你正在“引爆”它，这会释放出大量的躯体和那种令人不适的情绪能量。然后两三天后，很多时候，如果你能记住那是什么，它就会浮现出来。我的意思是，对我来说，我当时感觉非常脆弱，而且生气了大约两天。然后当我不再在意时，我才记起了发生在我身上的事情，并想，哦，是的，那真的很糟糕。如果有人告诉我发生了那种事，我会非常难过，但我已经为此难过了两天。那只是随之而来的画面。我结束了。
didn't care anymore, that's when I remembered the stuff that had happened to me and was like, Oh yeah, like that's really messed up. Like I would have been really upset if you told me that that happened and I remembered it, but I've already felt that for two days. That's just a picture that went with it. I'm done.
嗯，但是，是的。如果你路过，你可以顺便过来，你可以，你可以
Um, but, uh, yeah. If you're ever passing through, you stop by, you can, you can,
你可以尝试一下，你知道，很多……这是我们感到兴奋的事情之一。如果你路过，你可以尝试一下，你知道，很多……这是我们对播客工作室感到兴奋的事情之一，因为你不需要……你知道，如果你想做一些严肃的长期工作，找个治疗师是件好事，但它们太快了，你知道，我可以在五分钟内向你展示一个点以及它的感觉……就像是……但是的，很多时候它会激发创造力等等。所以，你知道，艺术家之后会有这样的时期，但如果你感兴趣，你可能想查一下做这个的人。这是一个奇怪的世界。
you can try them, you know, a lot of, that's one of the things that were excited. The through you stop by you can you can you can try them you know a lot of that's one of the things that we're excited the podcast studio because you can you don't you know if you want to do some serious long-term work finding a therapist is a good thing but they're so fast you know like i can show you a spot and what it feels like in in just five minutes um like it's but yeah the a lot of times it spikes creativity and stuff. And so, you know, artists will have these kinds of periods afterwards, but you may want to look up, um, somebody who does that. If you're interested, it's a, it's a weird world.
它和九十年代的东西不一样。真的吗？是的。我不知道你是否曾经……我读过大卫·林奇（David Lynch）的采访，他去接受心理治疗，他说，第一次治疗时他问，这会影响我的创造力吗？我的意思是，大卫·林奇就是那样说话的。这会影响我的创造力吗？然后治疗师说，
It's not the same stuff that was around in the nineties. Really? Yeah. I don't know if you've ever, uh, um, I read an interview with David Lynch and he went to therapy and he goes, the first session he goes, will this at all impact? I mean, that's how David Lynch talks. Will this at all impact my creativity? And the therapist goes,
可能会。他说，那我就得走了。我当时想，我认为心理治疗可以以一种惊人的方式影响你的创造力。它拓宽了你可以用来绘画的色彩。我认为那种认为艺术家必须是饱受折磨的天才，当你消除痛苦时艺术就会消失的观点，是80年代和90年代过时的看法。那是一种精神分析、新弗洛伊德主义的心理分析概念，并不是真的。谈论痛苦很长时间并不意味着你突然就无话可说了，并不是
it could. And he goes, then I have to go. I was like, I think, I think therapy can impact your creativity in a phenomenal way um it broadens the colors you can paint with when i think it's like a dated perception of the 80s and 90s that the artist has to be super tortured genius and that when you take away the pain then the art goes away like that that is kind of a psychoanalytic neo-freudian psychoanalytic concept that isn't really true um that talking about the pain for a super long time all of a sudden you know you no longer have anything to say isn't
而是你能够讲述它，并且你感受它的速度快得多。因为脑点疗法，我做过催眠和存在主义疗法，然后多年来更多地转向了荣格学派，心理治疗中也会发生同样的过程，它只是加速了这一过程，让你感受到你曾经觉得“我永远无法在情感上回到那里，因为那会杀了我”的东西。那种东西压倒了你，你学会了你可以承受它，然后突然间你会想，哦，哇，我可以做所有这些其他的事情，我只是被允许这样做。但它……突然间你会想，哦，哇，我可以做所有这些其他的事情。我只是被允许这样做。但这只需要一周，你知道，而不是几个月的时间来引导某人达到那个状态。
it it's that you're being able to tell and you feel it a lot faster um because brain spotting and i did hypnosis and existential therapy and kind of then got more into a yungian leaning thing for years and the same process happens in therapy it just speeds it up so fast where you feel something that you felt like i can never go back there emotionally because it would kill me that thing overwhelms you you learn that you can hold it and then all of a sudden you're like oh wow i can do all this other stuff i'm just allowed to do that but it all of a sudden you're like, oh, wow, I can do all this other stuff. I'm just allowed to do that. But it's like a week, you know, instead of months of getting somebody there.
我认为更新的观点不是“艺术家是受折磨和悲伤的”。当你消除童年的痛苦时，我就不想再唱歌了。而是我正在学习区分我的直觉、我的创造力，以及我的创伤、我的创伤反应、神经质地做某事的需要，或者虚伪地做某事，你知道，或者控制我被看待的方式。这与我真正想表达的东西分离开来。你知道，这就是我在小说和非虚构写作中感受到的。是的，是的，是的，我想补充一点，把你的东西发给我，因为我很乐意去看看。当你没有什么可隐瞒的时候，是的，心理治疗帮助我只是去想，我有什么
And I think the newer thing is not, oh, the artist is tortured and sad. When you take the pain of childhood away, then I don't want to sing anymore. It's that I'm learning to tell the difference between my intuition and my creativity and my intuition and creativity and my trauma my trauma reaction the need to neurotically do something or pretentiously do it um you know or to to control how i'm seen it being separated from what i actually want to say you know that's what i that's what i feel in my fiction and non-fiction writing um yeah yeah yeah i'd like to add send me your stuff because i'd love to i'd love to check it out it's it's when you have nothing to hide yeah therapy helped me just go what have i got
可隐瞒的？我不是地球上唯一不完美的人。所以当你，你知道，展示你怪异的一面时，人们会说，嘿。对的人会向你走来。还有那些疯狂的人。是的，你确实开始与那些你原本不会遇到的人建立联系。这几乎有一种共鸣，或者类似的东西。好吧，我们会把大家引向你的网站。你最近有什么演出吗？
to hide i'm not i'm not like the only imperfect person on earth so when you you know fly your freak flag people go go, hey. And the right people walk towards it. And the crazy people. Yeah, you do start to connect with people that you wouldn't have found otherwise. There is almost something resonant about it or something like that. Well, we'll point everybody to your website. And do you have any shows coming up?
你最近有什么演出吗？你有什么……比如，有没有一个地方是你更希望人们去购买专辑的，这对艺术家来说比仅仅流媒体播放更好？是的。
Do you have any shows coming up? Do you have any, uh, like, and is there a place that you prefer people to buy an album that is better for the artist than, you know, just streaming it or something? Yeah.
是的，Bandcamp 是最好的，特别是 Bandcamp 周五，因为百分之百的收入都归艺术家所有。但也只是在我的网站 JeffreySiler.com 上。我们有周边页面，你知道，
Yeah. Band camp is the best, particularly band camp Fridays because it a hundred, a hundred percent goes to the artist, but also just on my website, Jeffrey Siler.com. We've got the merge page and, you know,
那很有帮助。所以，我的意思是，是的，你真的不知道这有多大帮助。而且，因为我不得不压制 CD 的实体副本，
that helps out a lot. So, I mean, yeah, you actually have no idea how much it helps. And, uh, because I had to press physical copies of a CD,
为了唱片，为了电台。所以有时人们喜欢拥有这种遗物来感受那种感觉。电台仍然要求你邮寄实体 CD 以获得电台的最佳保真度。是的，当你默默无闻时，我确定
uh, for record, like for, uh, radio. So sometimes people like to have the relic to feel the feels. The radio stations still make you mail them a physical CD for the optimal fidelity on the radio. Yeah, and when you're unknown, I'm sure
对于更成熟的艺术家，他们可以直接发送链接，但当你默默无闻时，你真的在争夺注意力。好吧，奥斯汀是个好地方。看起来那里有很多好的音乐和艺术。所以，嗯，我们肯定会链接到那个。嗯，
with more established artists, they can just get the link, but you're really vying for attention when you're unknown. Well, Austin's a good place to be. It seems like there's a lot of good music and art coming out of there. So, um, we'll definitely link to that. Um,
我会链接到 Bandcamp。嗯，如果你想买，周五买，然后我们会……或者这是每个周五，还是他们做的某个特别的周五？我不知道。老实说，任何
I'll link to the band camp. Um, if you want to buy it, buy it on a Friday and then we will, or is it every Friday or is it like a special Friday that they do it? I don't know. Honestly, any,
一周中的任何一天，如果他们有兴趣，不要等待，你知道，尽可能多地享受它。如果你没有钱，那也没关系，Spotify 也可以。但是的，这种聆听是非常慷慨的。而且，你打算巡演并推广它吗？或者除了你的网站之外，还有什么地方人们可以查看并获取更新吗？加入邮件列表？是的，只需 Instagram。是的，加入邮件列表是最有帮助的事情，你可以在我的网站上这样做。如果你想看现场演出日期，比如我6月2日在 Far Out Lounge，6月21日在 Captain Quack's 演出，
any day of the week, if, if, if they're so inclined don't wait you know like enjoy as much as you can and if you don't have the money that's fine spotify is fine but yeah i it's like the listening is very generous yeah and and you are you do you plan to tour and promote it or is there a place people can check and get updates other than your website for something like that? Get on a mailing list? Yeah, just Instagram. Yeah, that's the most helpful thing to join the mailing list and you can do that on my site. And then if you want to see live dates, like I'm playing June 2nd at the Far Out Lounge and June 21st at Captain Quack's
都在奥斯汀。好的。好吧，是的。听起来很棒。如果 YouTube 不把它撤下并告诉我必须上传所有权证明，我会用你的音乐作为开场和结尾。
both here in Austin. Okay. Well, yeah. That sounds great. I will use your music to play you in and play you out with this if YouTube doesn't take it down and tell me that I have to upload proof of ownership.
回到亚特兰大时，我和汤姆住在一起，我们有一个 U-Haul 阁楼……上传所有权证明。你所需要的一切。噢。噢。那一年我发誓不再碰女孩。让我向你保证，作为一个群体，她们甚至连耸肩都没有。然后尽管有警钟，我还是无可救药地爱上了米歇尔。给那个爱自己的人弹奏竖琴。谢谢。无论你多么努力，心会决定。心会决定。你知道心会决定。当我到达加利福尼亚时，
Back in Atlanta when I lived with Tom we had a U-Haul loft upload proof of ownership. All you could need. Ooh. Ooh. That was the year I swore off girls. And let me assure you, as a group, they didn't even shrug. Then despite alarm bells, I fell headlong for Michelle. Put a harp along to what's-his-face, who was in love with himself. Thank you. How hard you try, the hard decides. The hard decides. You know the hard decides. By the time I got to California,
书架上有一个自助区，但在检查时，当他们在自己的倒影中沾沾自喜时，甚至没有一页狗耳朵，这当然是你找到真爱的时候，把其他一切都搁置一边的完美借口。他们说讽刺的是，我们本可以治愈彼此的痛苦。浪费了最初的十年。拉扯和推开。
had a self-help section of a bookshelf between the but upon inspection, while they gloat in their reflection, not even a page of dog, which of course is when you find real love, the perfect excuse to put everything else on hold. The irony they say is we could have been healing each other's pain. Wasted those first ten years. Pulling and pushing away.
难道不是这样吗？当时一切都说得通。你抗拒它，喂养它，假装不需要它。无论你多么努力，心会决定。心会决定。你知道心会决定。就在上周，我和汤姆吃了午饭，
Ain't that the way? It all made sense at the time. You fight it, feed it, pretend not to need it No matter how hard you try The hard decides The hard decides You know the hard decides Just last week I got lunch with Tom
我说很抱歉在他离婚期间没有打电话。一切都好，因为我自己也处于同样的境地。我们侥幸脱身，但这对我们的健康造成了损害。如果你是圣人，你所吃的东西适用。盛宴在人类谦卑的馅饼片上干涸。
And I said sorry for not calling during his divorce It was all just as well Cause I'd been in the same boat myself We got out by the skin of our teeth But it took its toll on our health And if the saint you are Out by the skin of our teeth, but it took its toll on our health. And if the saint you are, what you eat applies. Feast dries on a slice of human humble pie.
我经历过高潮和低谷，也和朋友闹翻过。总是感觉在外面往里看。我学会了如何给予。我正在学习如何需要。还在学习如何不把自己看得太严肃。难道不是这样吗？当时一切都说得通。你在战斗，被打败，假装不需要它。无论你多么努力，心会决定。心会决定。
I've had highs and lows and fallouts with friends. Always feeling on the outside looking in. I've learned how to give. I'm learning how to need. Still learning how not to take myself so seriously. Ain't that the way it all made sense at the time? You're fighting, defeated, pretend not to need it. No matter how hard you try, the heart decides. The heart decides.
你知道心会决定。谢谢。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
You know the heart decides. Thank you. Bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你知道，心会做出决定。谢谢。再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。